Och, Champ.
Wettke.
Ich müsste es mal probieren, ob ich es schaffe, den ganzen Twitch-Stream nur in Emotes zu sprechen.
Wahrscheinlich.
Das Schlimme ist, wahrscheinlich würde ich das so hinkriegen.
Ja, Leute.
Twitch hat so nicht kapiert, dass der Stream on ist.
Wartet mal, ich refreshe mal kurz die Anzeige bei mir auf dem Vorschau-Monitor.
Moin.
Die Anzeige geht noch nicht.
Ah, jetzt hat Twitch mitgekriegt, dass das...
Angeblich sind es null Zuschauer, was ja nicht sein kann, Leute.
Da sind quasi drei durch null.
Gleich ist Twitch kaputt.
Und wir sind dran schuld.
Vier durch null.
Fünf durch null.
Schwierig.
Oder wie sagt man da heutzutage?
Zu belastend.
Oh, der ist schon wieder out.
Ich glaube, das sagt man heute auch nicht mehr.
Wo ist der Kaboom?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Wir haben eine Weile schon nicht mal miteinander gesprochen.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ich vermute mal immer noch.
In Frankfurt irgendwo.
Naja.
Übrigens, heute machen wir was ganz Tolles.
Heute machen wir den Internetführerschein.
Es gibt einen neuen Internetführerschein.
Aber ich warte jetzt erstmal, bis der Stream richtig on ist.
Das wird was, ich sag's euch.
Der...
Das Bundesinnenministerium hat einen neuen Internetführerschein rausgebracht.
Und den machen wir heute.
Hat sechs Kategorien in drei verschiedenen Schwierigkeitsstufen.
Nein, der ist angeblich wirklich ernst gemeint.
Ich habe nur meine...
Ich habe nur meine Zweifel, ob das wirklich so ist.
Weiß...
Bin mir nicht so sicher.
Trimulon, danke für den Sub.
Take Viagra die hard.
Danke für den Sub.
Huge Pog.
Du bist zertifizierter Datenschutzbeauftragter.
Huge.
Upgrade.
Karrierepass Upgrade.
Gut, ich meine, ich hoffe, du kriegst wenigstens jetzt da was.
Ich hoffe, es lohnt sich wenigstens.
Ich schau mal...
Zumindest ist es schon mal nicht schlecht zu haben.
Hast du...
Hast du denn auch den neuen Internetführerschein?
Wenn nicht, den machen wir heute, Leute.
Du hast...
Du hast auf der Seite 404...
Ernsthaft, ist das schon wieder kaputt?
Probieren wir gleich aus. Probieren wir gleich aus.
Vorhin ging's noch.
Vor... Vorhin hat's noch funktioniert.
Das ist Haare sträuben teilweise, was da drin steht.
Da steht drinnen, Herr Stefanie beauftragt Sie.
Da haben irgendwie fünf Leute zusammen an einer Frage geschrieben.
Ist ganz grausam.
Na gut, vielleicht gibt's auch einen Herr Stefanie.
Heutzutage kann man sowas ja nicht mehr assumen.
Dann ist ganz schnell der Spaß vorbei, wenn man sowas macht.
War nur ne Schulung, Arbeit hab ich schon.
Achso, na dann.
Der POG, der Internetführerschein, der ist ganz wichtig, ja?
Soll ich euch mal was erzählen, Leute?
Oh nein, Avira will mir wieder Premium aufschwätzen.
Warum hab ich diesen Scheiß überhaupt noch auf dem zweiten Rechner inszeniert?
Das ist so useless.
Hier ist nix.
Zehn Monate, danke für den Sub.
Was Crosstalk Solutions hat heute UI Notify gelauncht?
Äh, was? Wie?
Ist das Gbait?
Das ist doch Werbung, oder?
Das ist doch Werbung!
Ist das Werbung?
Sascha, ist das verpackte Werbung?
ModCheck?
Es soll keine Werbung sein.
Es liest sich aber wie Werbung.
Ja, Kommentare gelöscht kann auf Youtube alles bedeuten.
Da weiß man nicht so genau.
Früher landeten die Kommentare auf Youtube in so einem Bereich,
wo man dann als Content Creator gesehen hat,
dass Kommentare geblockt wurden
und man konnte die wieder freigeben.
Aber mittlerweile landet die meistens...
das Meisterzeug gar nicht mehr da.
Was der Kollege in der Firma
Kaspersky entfernt, weil die aus Russland
kommt. Kappa HD, ja.
Kommen die überhaupt aus Russland?
Waren die nicht
irgendwie nur aus...
Kaspersky
Antivirus.
Waren die nicht irgendwie aus Litauen oder sowas?
Oder bringe ich das jetzt durcheinander?
Ja? Okay, ne, dann bringe
ich das durcheinander.
Tatsächlich.
Ne, die kommen wirklich
nicht aus Russland.
Ich dachte, die kommen aus...
Mit was verwechsel ich die denn?
Fällt euch irgendein Antivirus-Zeug aus Litauen ein?
Wahrscheinlich bin ich komplett neben der Spur.
Moment, was?
In welchen Programmiersprachen ist das
geschrieben? C++
und Nemerle?
Was zum Teufel ist Nemerle für eine Programmiersprache?
Was?
Äh.
Das ist quasi ein Fakesy-Sharp für...
Boah, ne.
Boah.
F-Sharp-Abklassen.
Klatsch.
Ne, ne, ne, ne.
Das will ich mir gar nicht weiter angucken.
In was das alles programmiert ist.
Nemerle, Allah, hab ich noch nie gehört.
Aber gut.
Kaspersky wird's schon wissen.
Ja, ich wollte euch ja was als...
Warum ist denn das jetzt da unten
rot? Ist das jetzt normal, wenn man
streamt?
Normalerweise, früher war das immer nur rot,
wenn man recordet.
Ich vermute mal, das ist jetzt auch rot, wenn man...
Das hat mich jetzt irritiert, will ich das mal
in der Festplatte gleich voll ist, weil...
Ich hab nicht mehr so viel Platz.
Es ist, es ist, es ist ein bisschen...
Es ist ein bisschen eng, auf manchen meiner Laufwerke, ja?
Also hier ist es ein bisschen eng.
Da ist es ein bisschen eng.
Da ist Platz, aber da ist...
Also...
Weiß nicht so genau.
Das... Mir war so... Ich wusste es.
Ich wollte es nicht sagen.
Ich wusste, ich, als ich es ausgesprochen habe,
wusste ich, dass irgendjemand...
schreibt, entweder bissl eng,
gatschibass, oder eng ist gut, irgendwie
sowas. Es war mir jetzt so klar.
Ich kenn den Chat mittlerweile.
Ich weiß halt schon Bescheid, was da los ist.
Manchmal ist mir schon klar, während ich was ausspreche,
weiß ich, da kommt jetzt das, und das ist
immer meistens so. 99% der Fälle.
Hast du noch 2TB
auf einer Platte frei? Soll ich dir
meine 1TB Platte schicken,
die ich bei meiner letzten Kiste aus Versehen
mitgeordert habe?
Baracuda, Seagate Baracuda
1TB.
Wobei, das ist... Versandkosten sind teurer, als
die Festplatte in Prime
bei Amazon zu bestellen.
Ah, der Preischamp.
Der Preischamp ist offline.
Der Preischamp, den gibt es nicht mehr.
Den Preischamp, da solltest du eigentlich
noch nicht mal einen 404 kriegen. Beim
Preischamp solltest du eigentlich...
Ach so, ich hab Cloudflare noch nicht
gelöscht.
Deswegen gibts nen 404, oder?
Hab ich Cloudflare schon gelöscht?
Sehen wir gleich.
Ich bilde mir eigentlich ein, ich hab alle schon gelöscht, aber...
Dann hab ich Cloudflare
vielleicht nicht gelöscht.
Na gut.
Soll ich euch mal was erzählen? Übrigens,
ich zeige euch erstmal, was wir heute machen.
Der Defu.
Digital...
Wie hießen die?
Defu.
Doch, der Defu.
Defu.de haben die sogar.
Eine
Umlaut-Domain.
Eine Emoji-Domain.
Also damit, mit diesen Escapes
kann man auch Emoji-Domains machen.
Guckt euch das mal an.
So, das machen wir gleich.
Aber vorher muss ich euch noch was erzählen.
Könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern?
Ihr habt
mich sogar letzten Sonntag danach
gefragt. Könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern, als
ich euch erzählt hab, ich musste letzten Montag
was präsentieren
auf der Arbeit. Wobei, was heißt ich musste?
Ich hab das sogar freiwillig gesagt, ich mach das.
Und ich muss was präsentieren
und
ich hab euch ja auch erzählt, ich werd mich wahrscheinlich
nicht sonderlich beliebt dabei machen.
Könnt ihr euch wahrscheinlich
noch dran erinnern, weil es haben mich sogar am Sonntag
viele gefragt, so, und Max, wie lief's denn?
Und am Sonntag hab ich noch gesagt, jawoll, lief
wunderbar. Und heute, Leute,
ich sag euch, wir wurden
heute, ich hab das ja mit einem Kollegen zusammen gemacht,
alter Patrick, 32
Monate Hyper-Subscription jetzt, geht's ab.
Richtig pock, dankeschön.
So, wo bin
ich stehen geblieben? Genau, und heute,
und heute,
wir wurden übertrieben gelobt.
Das erlebt man bei
mir auf der Arbeit selten, ja.
Wir wurden übertrieben gelobt,
wie toll das war, dass
wir das präsentiert haben, und es hat
manchen Leuten die Augen geöffnet.
Und da hab ich mir auch schon gedacht,
easy clap.
Wisst ihr, wisst ihr, was ich
eigentlich, was wir eigentlich gemacht haben?
Wir haben eine halbe Stunde,
eigentlich durchgängig erzählt,
wie kacke
so eine gewisse Sache ist bei uns.
Aber anscheinend
musste das mal sein.
Was hast du präsentiert? Ich muss mal kurz gucken,
wie ich das am besten überschreibe.
Ich habe über die Probleme
beim remote arbeiten
berichtet.
Und wie bei uns
Sicherheit und
Bedienbarkeit in Konflikt
steht. Ich glaub, so kann man das
ganz gut beschreiben.
Weil es wird immer, Leute, ich erzähl euch was.
Passt mal auf, passt mal auf. Eine
absolut abgedrehte Ausgeburt
der Hölle, die sie sich jetzt überlegt haben
bei uns auf der Arbeit. Also,
ähm,
damit,
huch, jetzt hat die Musik geruckelt.
So, damit du bei uns
auf wichtige
Systeme kommst, remote,
wenn du Homeoffice machst oder sowas,
kannst du nicht einfach nur
dich
irgendwie connecten oder
kommst du überall hin. Nein, das ist ein bisschen
komplizierter gemacht, was ja prinzipiell auch kein Problem
ist. Du verbindest
dich per 2-Faktor-Authentifizierung
auf ein Portal.
In diesem Portal,
ich hab mir das schon gleich aufgeschrieben in
mein Dokument.
So.
In diesem Portal machst du dann
eine Shitrix VM auf
und von dort
kannst du dich dann connecten.
Da ist auch ein bisschen mehr drum herum, aber ich will jetzt nicht alles genau
erzählen. So.
Das war schon
in der Vergangenheit ein bisschen
gewöhnungsbedürftig.
Aber
das war insofern
okay, weil man das
meistens wirklich nur für
live
Administrationszeug
es ist mega clunky und laggy
as fuck, für Administrationszeug
gebraucht hat. Und Wolle,
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Und deswegen es
ging. Man konnte sich dann auch irgendwie tunneln,
auch wenn es nur so Grauzone war, ob das
überhaupt erlaubt ist. So.
Aber jetzt haben sie den Vogel abgeschossen.
Jetzt haben sie den Vogel abgeschossen.
Die ganze Zeit war das so,
für Datenaustausch
konnte man
entweder VPN verwenden,
also was weiß ich, wenn ich irgendwelche
größeren Sachen irgendwie
rumkopieren muss, ja. Also
sei es, dass die Sekretärin irgendeine
50 MB Excel Datei
kopieren muss oder dass man Logs mal rumkopieren muss
oder so. So. Also für Datenaustausch
hatte man folgendes. Entweder VPN
oder
man konnte das Notebook aus der Firma mitnehmen
oder sich sogar heimschicken lassen, wenn man
Dauer Home Office hat. Oder
man hatte eine normale Office
VM, auch über Shitrix.
So. Und da gab es dann
ein gemeinsames, also
ein Windows Share
für seinen User
und die Musik ist ein bisschen lauter.
Außerdem ist die Musik
äußerst nervös.
Sie ist mir immer noch zu nervös.
Die mag zwar happy sein,
ja,
viel besser.
So. Und
dann haben sie sich...
Irgendwie ist die Musik jetzt zu nervig gerade.
Okay.
Gut. Ähm,
wunderbar. Also, wo bin ich
stehen geblieben? Ja, also du
konntest Datenaustausch noch halbwegs
normal machen. Du hattest so einen
Windows Share für deinen User. Da konntest du
Zeug drüber kopieren. Das war auch relativ schnell.
Ist alles okay gewesen. So. Und jetzt kommt der Hammer.
Das war so auch mit der Stein des Anstoßes,
als ich gesagt habe, jetzt reicht es, kann ich nicht mehr
arbeiten. Ich kann mich auch gerne hinsetzen,
ohne was zu machen und ihr gebt mir Geld, aber
das kann so nicht sein. Man hat sich
jetzt folgendes überlegt.
Jetzt haltet euch fest.
Wir ersetzen, also sie ersetzen
den Windows
Share durch OneDrive.
So. Und jetzt erzähle ich euch
mal ein wirklich praktisch
so passiertes
Anwendungsszenario.
Ein
Kollege von mir, das habe ich euch, das habe ich euch
ja schon mal vor einer Weile erzählt,
dass wir in der Richtung was gemacht haben,
hat, hat, ja, ja
OneDrive, OneDrive. Ein
Kollege von mir hat Hilfe gebraucht bei
Log-Auswertung. Der hatte glaube
ich irgendwie zwei Terabyte Squidlogs.
Und die Squidlogs sollten durchsucht
werden, ob irgendwelche speziellen
Aufrufe drin sind, um daraus ableiten
zu können, ob Firewall-Regeln noch
gebraucht werden. Ist egal, warum. So.
Zumindest Squidlogs durchsuchen.
Also, was haben wir gemacht?
Haben gesagt, hey, das haben wir doch schon mal gemacht.
Ich hatte nämlich, er hatte das
damals in Bash programmiert.
Und ohne Scheiß, Bash hat eine Woche
die Squidlogs durchsucht. Eine Woche,
Leute, eine Woche.
So, danach sind wir hingegangen,
haben ein .NET-Programm gebastelt.
Multithreaded, 24 Kerne auf
einer richtig fetten Kiste.
Multithreaded, 24 Kerne,
das meiste auch noch irgendwie 128 GB
RAM, das meiste im RAM gehalten, mit
einem Dictionary
gedifft, gemacht, geguckt, gezählt,
gecountet. Am Ende lief es irgendwie
40 Minuten oder so, versus eine Stunde.
Also, 40 Minuten Programm
in C-Sharp, multithreaded, versus
eine Woche in Bash. Das kann durchaus
sein. Bash ist nicht sonderlich effektiv, vor allem, wenn man
das auch noch ein bisschen umständlich macht.
So. Und
das war, das war der Plan.
Wir haben gesagt, weißt du was? Haben wir doch schon mal gemacht.
Wir nehmen einfach dieses Programm
und passen das, passen das an
für den neuen Anwendungsfall. So.
Und jetzt haltet euch fest. Jetzt,
jetzt kommt's. Mein, mein
Datenaustausch.
Wie lange habt ihr da dran programmiert? Das ist nicht
sonderlich kompliziert. Zwei, drei Stunden?
Das war nicht, ist kein großer Akt
gewesen. Zumindest
dadurch, dass ich jetzt kein
Share mehr habe, den
ich irgendwie von einem Notebook verwenden kann, von
einer VM verwenden kann, von einer Administrationskiste
verwenden kann. Ich hab kein Windows Share, also ich hab
kein Share mehr. Musste ich jetzt
folgendes machen.
Als erstes, musste
ich mir eine Beispiel-Log-Datei ziehen.
Das ging nicht.
Weil der Virenscanner
gesagt hat, die Datei ist größer als 30 MB,
wird abgebrochen.
Ist bestimmt Ransomware.
So, also Test-Logs
ziehen hat schon mal nicht funktioniert.
Okay. Aber jetzt kommt, jetzt kommt,
jetzt kommt der absolute Hit.
Jetzt kommt der absolute Hit.
Ich hab dann, weil ich es ums Verrecken
nicht machen konnte, mit
der, mit
der VM, die mir die Firma zur Verfügung
stellt, hab ich lokal bei mir
eine Ubuntu-VM gebootet.
Mit Rider
und allem, was ich an Entwicklung
brauche für .NET-Programme.
Hab mir ein
Log-Auszug kopiert, 10 MB
und hab das angepasst.
Das Programm. So.
Also allein schon, dass ich das auf einer privaten
VM machen muss, ist halt absolut lächerlich, dass die Firma
das dann auf die Reihe kriegt. So.
Und jetzt, und jetzt, und jetzt, und jetzt kommt wirklich
der Hit. Das war, ich war fertig,
hab's kompiliert
und wir wissen ja, sobald's kompiliert,
funktioniert das auch.
Und jetzt war die Frage,
wie krieg ich dieses Programm denn
auf die fette 24-Kerne-Kiste
drauf, wo die Logs drauf liegen
zum Auswerten. Ich hatte keinen
gemeinsamen Share mehr und ich hab allen Ernstes
jetzt, kein Witz,
ich musste mich lokal auf meiner
Ubuntu-VM in meinem OneDrive einloggen,
das Programm dort hochladen,
dann musste ich mich über eine
Shitrix-Administrations-VM verbinden,
dort das Programm runterladen
von OneDrive, dann
per SCP auf den
Produktions-Jump-Host kopieren,
von dort auf den Server
kopieren und dann starten
und dann feststellen
und dann feststellen, dass ich was
vergessen hab und wieder von vorne.
Ohne Scheiß, das hat zwei
Stunden gedauert. Für fünfmal
kompiliert oder so. Das war der
absolute Over-Up-Fuck.
1-Up-Workflow.
Ja, richtig geil.
Richtig krasser Business-
Enterprise-Workflow, ne?
Musst du dich auch mit Microsoft Access? Nein,
zum Glück nicht.
Richtiger Lean-Up.
Safe. Safe und Lean ist der.
Ja. ITIL-zertifiziert
auch noch. DIN ISO 9001.
Alles auf einmal. So.
Und ganz ehrlich,
da war der Punkt erreicht, wo ich gesagt, Leute,
ich kann so nicht
arbeiten, also erstens will ich so nicht arbeiten,
ich kann auch so nicht arbeiten und
das müssen wir jetzt mal ein bisschen
an die größere Glocke hängen.
Und deswegen haben wir das letzte
Woche vorgestellt auf
einer abteilungsübergreifenden
Security-Runde. Da waren alle möglichen
Abteilungsleiter da und
die sind da letzten Montag da irgendwie
aus allen Wolken gefallen. Und heute
hat uns dann jemand
erzählt, dass das halt eben eine ganz tolle
augenöffnende
Präsentation war. Was im Endeffekt
heißt, ihnen war gar nicht klar,
wie beschissen das ist.
Was sie da gebaut haben.
Oh Mann.
Aber sagen Sie, also
entweder ist das die Standard-Taktik,
so nach dem Motto, boah habt ihr gut gemacht,
wir schmeißen euch jetzt raus.
Oder die fanden das wirklich gut.
Kann ja sein.
Zumindest scheint
ihnen klar zu sein. Aber ich hab auch wirklich,
wir haben denen auch wirklich
alles, alles aufs Brot geschmiert.
Also die Präsentation lief ungefähr so ab.
Also ganz, ganz
grob. Wir haben gesagt, ja hallo hier,
Max, und hallo hier, Dings,
mit dem ich das gemacht hab. Die meisten
kennen uns ja, aber wir sind jetzt auch mal hier am Start.
Und heute müssen wir ein bisschen
meckern und das und das und das kommt
heute. Und dann
hab ich gleich mit einem richtigen Knaller
gestartet. Ich hab einen Screenshot gemacht, als die
Administrations-VM
das letzte Mal zu wenig
RAM hatte und mein Browser gecrashed ist. Hab ich gleich
gescreenshottet. Ich hab sogar extra
ein GIF danach noch gemacht.
Von den Dingern,
die abgekackt sind.
Da hab ich gesagt, so die admin-VM
langsam, laggy,
copy-paste geht nicht und manchmal
verliert man seine Arbeit, weil es crasht.
Und das fanden
da konnten sich auch irgendwelche
Excel-Schubser relaten dazu und haben
das verstanden.
Dass das keine gute Idee ist. Ja und dann
haben wir danach noch
danach hat
mein Kollege übernommen
und ähm, nein die Präsentation
hatte nur Emojis, keine
Twitch-Emojis.
So, zumindest danach
hab ich gemeint, so ich übergebe jetzt mal kurz hier an meinen
Kollege, ich sag jetzt den Namen nicht,
weil ich kann sagen, Tim heißt er, das ist ja
nix, nix, nix geheimes.
Aber ich sag, ich übergebe jetzt an den Tim
und der erzählt jetzt nochmal die
äh, vielen Kleinigkeiten,
die an der admin-VM nerven.
Da hat der Tim angefangen, ohne Scheiß. Vier Seiten.
Vier Seiten. Erster Punkt, zweiter Punkt,
dritter Punkt, vierter Punkt, fünfter Punkt, sechster Punkt,
achter, dritter Punkt, der hat das auch so richtig
der hat das auch so richtig durchgeradert.
Vier Seiten. Einfach so.
Einfach so in fünf Minuten, bam, bam, bam,
mit Punkt drauf,
die alle kacke sind.
Und danach hat den schon der Kopf geraucht, da hab ich gedacht,
was, so viel ist da im Arsch?
Und dann bin ich nochmal dran gekommen und hab nochmal
hab ich das
Beispiel gebracht mit dem OneDrive
kopieren und noch ein anderes Beispiel
und ich glaube spätestens
dann war vorbei.
Ich glaub da hatten wir
sie alle insofern überzeugt, dass das so wie es
jetzt ist, absolut kacke ist.
So, und warum erzähl ich euch das Ganze jetzt?
Nicht nur weil wir irgendwie,
nicht nur weil sie uns super gelobt haben, was ich natürlich
immer tolle find, ja.
Kann ich, kann ich gleich,
sag ich gleich was zu?
Nein, nein, noch viel besser. Typische
Business Enterprise Move würde heute versucht.
Die haben uns erstmal, die haben uns,
die haben uns total gelobt, haben gesagt, oh, war ja richtig,
hat die richtig Augen geöffnet
an die Präsentation und sonst was. Hab ich schon gedacht, oh nein,
joa, freut mich, freut mich.
Und dann kam die Frage,
und jetzt haltet euch fest, das ist so die typische
Business Enterprise Frage, dann haben,
dann wollten sie uns fragen so, ja,
ob wir denn dieses Thema jetzt auch weiter
vorantreiben können?
Hab ich mir so,
hab ich mir so gedacht, nee,
das dürft ihr schon,
dürft ihr schon schön selber machen.
Ich treib doch nicht,
ich, guck mal, ich schreib
mir doch nicht dieses Drecksthema auf
die Fahne.
Allen Ernstes, ob wir das Thema jetzt weiter
vorantreiben? Ich glaub, es geht los.
Das Einzige, wozu wir
uns haben breitschlagen lassen, ist,
ähm, dass wir jetzt
als Ansprechpartner
uns bereitstellen, wenn es
Updates für diese
Administrations-VM gibt,
und, äh, ob wir,
dass wir die dann testen, wenn's
die dann gibt. Ja?
Aber ganz bestimmt treibe ich jetzt diesen
Mist nicht weiter voran. Das ist
überhaupt nicht, das ist erstens über meiner Gehaltsklasse,
das ist auch überhaupt nicht mein Ding,
ich will damit auch nichts zu tun haben, ich will's
einfach nur benutzen, weil ich unterm
Strich einfach nur
arbeiten will,
ohne dass es mich die ganze Zeit abfuckt.
Ach du Scheiße.
Naja, gut. Wie alt bist du? Ich bin 37,
äh, ja, 37.
Ich bin 1984 geboren.
Ja, aber jetzt was zu dieser Frage,
bevor wir dann den Internetführerschein machen,
ähm,
das hat weder mit DevOps noch mit
Entwicklung noch mit sonst was zu tun, das ist Infrastruktur
bereitstellen, das hat mit meinem Zeug überhaupt nichts zu tun.
Zum Glück, ich hätt das überhaupt
nix, ich hätt mir garantiert keine
Shitrix-Geschichte hingestellt
zum Remote-Arbeiten.
So, äh, hier Radiosignal fragt,
hab ich das richtig verstanden? Du programmierst unter Linux
mit C-Sharp, kompilierst und schiebst dann das Programm
auf den Windows-Server, oder? Nein, nein, nein, das sind
Linux-Kisten. Alles Linux. Wir haben
zu 99% Linux bei uns.
Red Hat.
Red Hat kompatibel.
Sagen wir's mal so.
Gibt ja nicht viel, außer CentOS, was
es sein könnte, ne?
Es gab mal, früher gab's Scientific,
und jetzt gibt es Rocky,
Rocky, ich weiß nicht, ob Rocky irgendjemand schon
Rocky-Linux, äh, im Einsatz hat.
Äh, Suse, Suse ist
bläh. Nee, Red Hat kompatibel
bedeutet im Endeffekt nur, es ist quasi
in Red Hat mit Red Hat-Logos
entfernt. Das sind die Red Hat
Sources, neu kompiliert.
Ohne die Copyright-Sachen drin.
Ich hab nicht
studiert, nein, ich hab mal 2007
fachinformatiker Systemintegration gelernt.
Ja. Nee, nee, aber das sind
alles Linux-Kisten bei uns.
Wir haben ein paar Windows-Server, aber da hab ich,
Gott sei Dank, nichts mitzutun.
Ähm, Visual Studio
Code kann doch, äh,
Remote Code developen, über SSH würde
das gehen. Nee, nicht so einfach.
Tja.
Möglich.
Könnt,
könnte, könnte ich das vielleicht sein?
Ich mein,
ich hab das gleiche
Profilfoto,
ich hör mich genau so an,
ich laber den gleichen
Scheiß, ich würd sagen,
Exposed.
Oh Mann.
Okay.
Leute.
Ja, und mein YouTube-Kanal ist auch verlinkt.
So, das dachte ich mir, das muss ich euch jetzt mal erzählen.
Jetzt gucken wir, jetzt machen wir, jetzt machen wir den, den
den Digitalführerschein.
Wir müssen erst mal gucken, ob die Seite im Darkreader
besser aussieht. Naja.
Zumindest, zumindest kriegt man
nicht gleich Augenverbrennung, wenn man
sich die Seite anschaut.
So, also das ist jetzt neu. Das gibt's
dann heute. Kannst du dich noch an
mich erinnern? Wer bist du denn
auf YouTube?
Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Es gibt, es gibt ein paar, an die kann ich mich erinnern.
Oder es gibt ein paar Namen, wenn ich die sehe, kann ich
mich dran erinnern.
Aber bei fast 300.000 Abonnenten ist
es schwierig, da jetzt
im Detail jeden zu kennen, ne, ist ja klar.
Das ist echt, nein,
das ist echt, das ist echt,
es gibt jetzt wirklich, seit heute gibt es einen
neuen Internetführerschein.
Du dachtest,
wir sind alle deine Freunde. Ja, ihr seid
so, also wenn ihr Primes habt,
können wir da drüber reden.
Genau, aber genauso wie Bibi zufällig
die Uhr, die sie vorstellt, heute
im Laden entdeckt hat und nicht dafür gesponsert
wird.
Heißt er auf YouTube Helpful Guy,
einer deiner größten Fans damals?
Keine Ahnung, also
das ist schon so lang her, weiß ich nicht.
Sagt mir jetzt nix. Aber trotzdem
schön, dass du deinen Weg hierher gefunden hast.
Cringe, wenn ich seine
Abonnenten kenne, sag ich dazu nur.
Ja, also es war kein Meme-Titel,
ich mach heute wirklich den neuen
Digitalführerschein. So, und
was das sein soll,
ist, das ist
vom Bundesinnenministerium ein neuer
Online, wie nennt man das,
Fortbildungslernplattform
mit Tests,
wo man dann
angeblich, so schwebt es denen
vor, ich hab da ja so meine Zweifel,
wenn ich ehrlich bin, woran man dann
auch für den
beruflichen Weg, also quasi
für Jobsuche
und sonst was, sein
Digital- und
Internet-Know-How
unter Beweis stellen kann.
So, das sagen die,
nachdem das nicht das erste ist
in dieser Richtung,
und die letzten Versuche
in dieser Richtung ziemlich
beschissen waren, um's mal klar
zu sagen, hab ich meine
Zweifel, dass das was taugt.
Aber das gucken wir uns jetzt erstmal an.
Moritz, danke für den Sub.
Danke auch dir für den Sub, zwei Monate
huge Subscription hier.
Aber, die sind modern, die sind modern,
es ist Beta, es ist Beta.
Nicht Sigma, es ist Beta.
Ob da der EU-Kommissar,
der Oettinger für digitale
Digitalisierung, oder digital, bestimmt war
da der Oettinger mit am Start.
Deutschland sicher im Netz.
So, loslegen.
Wir gucken uns das jetzt an.
Also, zum
Defu-Lernangebot.
Wie möchtest du den Defu nutzen?
Okay, was ist der Unterschied?
Beruflicher Kontext.
Die Arbeitswelt bringt
ihre ganz eigenen Herausforderungen mit sich.
Unser Lernangebot im Beruf bietet ihnen Inhalte,
die speziell darauf zugestehen.
Alles klar, beruflicher Kontext, easy.
Level 1.
Ne, wir machen mal, wir machen mal eine Sache.
Wir fangen mal an, warum alles so groß ist,
weil mein Browser auf, wobei,
ne, ist auch sonst relativ groß.
Wir fangen mal privat Level 1 an.
Nur mal so, just for fun, um ein bisschen
zu kecken, was die, wie die Fragen so sind.
So, und dann gibt es dann
mehrere Kategorien mit jeweils 8 Fragen.
Geräte, Internet,
Kommunikation,
Datenwelt, Gefahrenschutz,
Technologie-Alltag.
So, und da kann man jetzt wohl irgendwie
einen Test machen. Wir machen jetzt einen Test.
Und jetzt müssen wir uns registrieren.
PogChamp.
Mail.
Jawoll.
E-Mail-Adresse.
Sag.
Ich muss noch kurz ein Passwort random generaten.
Leute, ich random generate jetzt ein Passwort.
Passt mal auf.
Excellent.
Boah, das ist das randomizedigste Passwort aller Zeiten.
So.
Vollständige Name.
Geburtstag. Wie Geburtstag war noch?
1.1.1900.
Ja, genau.
Indem ich fortfahre, stimmen sie in AGB.
Registrieren.
Jep, jep.
Gut. Wie?
bestätigungs e mail keine bestätigungs e mail was ist denn mit euch los war
nicht kein ok jetzt habe ich zugemacht wenn ich jetzt noch eine
bestätigungs e mail braucht bin ich nein ich habe ein passwort gelegt jetzt
könnt ihr euch alle bei die für einloggen für mich nein okay ich mache
neuen account das so geht das da nicht neuen account neuen account 10 minute mail
wir machen jetzt 9 10 not mail nein nein nein nein 10 minute mail .net
ok das ist jetzt neue wobei scheiß drauf was hatte ich was hatte ich vor ist doch
scheiß egal ob ihr das passwort seht ich habe ich habe sogar meine e mail leute
hat noch jemand e mail adresse von eben ich kann nur ich habe es zugemacht
einfach egal ich registriere mich jetzt neu so registrieren
jetzt können sie sich anmelden ich will mich neu registrieren
lasst mich registrieren neues passwort ok
geburtstag 1 1 und so 90 ok registrieren anmelden e mail adresse jawohl da sind
wir was erwartet dich in der diffi prüfung
was erwartet dich in der diffi prüfung
leute ich glaube ich muss euch flash
leute ich glaube ich muss euch flash bang mal gucken was erwartet dich wann
bang mal gucken was erwartet dich wann
bang mal gucken was erwartet dich wann gilt meine prüfung als bestanden moment
gilt meine prüfung als bestanden moment
gilt meine prüfung als bestanden moment mindestens 50 prozent der fragen was ist
mindestens 50 prozent der fragen was ist
mindestens 50 prozent der fragen was ist denn das für ein müll 50 prozent das
denn das für ein müll 50 prozent das
denn das für ein müll 50 prozent das kriegst du ja schon mit simplem
kriegst du ja schon mit simplem
kriegst du ja schon mit simplem randomisen hin normalerweise musste
randomisen hin normalerweise musste
randomisen hin normalerweise musste bei sowas 80 haben oder oder sowas
oder maximal zwei falsch oder 50 das ist ja mies okay ich bin einverstanden also
gucken wir uns das ganze mal das ist jetzt wohlgemerkt das ist für die
oberkack noobs privat nur zum warm werden ja also was nutzen smart home
geräte nicht zur datenübertragung push was auch immer push in dem kontext
bedeuten sollte weiter was würdest du sagen welche maßnahmen tragen im
smart home zur sicherheit bei regelmäßige installations von updates
ist gut passwort in der steuerungs app ist auch gut sicherheits index
einschalten was ist denn der sicherheits index okay
ihr wisst auch nicht oder
okay wir lassen es einfach mal ich habe keine ahnung was der sicherheits index
ist schalte den index ein okay was musst du beachten bevor du dir eine app auf
dein smart home nicht smartphone lädst okay bewertung im netz zur app lesen bei
schlechten bewertung die app lieber nicht ja das finde ich ist eine gute
idee kosten geprüft nicht alle apps kostenlos ja vor dem laden cookies
prüfen ich mein
ich mein
kann man machen aber wozu ergibt in diesem kontext wenig sinn
okay weiter der herr demir hat eine wetter app auf sein smartphone
heruntergeladen diese fordert die berechtigung ein auf das adressbuch oh
nein die russischen hacker sind am start zuzugreifen gekommen wird das ist die
die gehackte wetter app also leute ich muss auch kurz husten es ist
übrigens schon besser da in danke für die nachfrage letztens haben
ganz viele sich dafür interessiert ob alles wieder gutes husten schon deutlich
besser sollte viel viel besser okay also herr demir hat eine wetter app
aufs smartphone heruntergeladen diese fordert die berechtigung ein auf das
adressbuch im smartphone zugreifen sollte er der app bewertung die
berechtigung gewähren nein das braucht kein adressbuch aber mittlerweile gehört
sei zum guten ton dass du dich berechtigung anfragt ja telefonberechtigungen standort lokales
oston
Berechtigungen anfragst. Ja, Telefon
Berechtigungen, Standort
Lokal Berechtigungen,
Adressbuch Berechtigung, alle möglichen.
Du brauchst einfach Berechtigungen. Am Endeffekt ist
es irgendeine App, die
Cookie-Klicker macht oder sowas.
Aber machen wir, machen wir, machen wir.
Nein, die App braucht nur um das Wetter an. Okay.
Drucker. Was?
Ach, soll ich das jetzt rüber
tracken und droppen oder wie?
So?
Boah.
Also, ich meine, meine Oma
hätte den Test wahrscheinlich auch hingekriegt.
Aber wer braucht schon eine Erklärung dafür?
Ich meine, scheiß drauf. Einfach, einfach
oben hinschreiben. 5 von 8,
das reicht. Okay. Tastatur-App,
Virenschutz, wobei
man, wobei es da jetzt schon ein bisschen Grauzone
sein kann.
Ähm,
Drucker, Monitor, App-Store,
Tablet,
Betriebssystem. Alles klar. Next.
In welchem Store findest du Apps für
das Betriebssystem iOS, welches auf iPhones
installiert ist? Auf dem
Microsoft-Store. Ganz ehrlich, im
Microsoft-Store findet man auch nicht mal
Dinge auf Betriebssystem, die, wofür der Microsoft-Store
gedacht ist. Also, der Microsoft-Store,
den kannst du eigentlich immer streichen.
So, App-Store.
Wofür steht das W
in WLAN?
Wort? White?
Kabel und Wireless. Wire.
Wire. Das berühmte WLAN-Kabel.
Oh, jetzt wird's, jetzt wird's
advanced. Hier, 8 von 8.
Mo möchte ein Smart-Home-Gerät
kaufen.
Mo?
Das ist bestimmt die Abkürzung für
Moritz oder sowas. Mo.
Erinnert mich an die,
an die Diablo 2 Kühe.
Kann sich da noch einer trennen? Mo.
Mo, Mo, Mo, Mo.
Mo, Mo, Mo, Mo, Mo, Mo.
Es könnte auch
Mohamed sein, richtig. Es muss nicht Moritz sein.
Man weiß ja heutzutage nicht.
So. Und, und man
weiß auch nicht, ob Mo er ist.
Es könnte ja auch sie sein, oder?
Sonst was.
Fahrräder und Helikopter und was noch?
Keine Ahnung.
Also, Mo möchte ein Smart-Home-Gerät kaufen.
Naja, nicht triggert sein Chat.
Nicht gleich, nicht gleich wieder ausrasten, ja?
Tweet ist raus.
Direkt. So.
Mo möchte ein Smart-Home-Gerät kaufen. Leider sind die
alle sehr teuer.
Er hat eine viel günstigere Kopie eines Geräts
bei einem Hersteller aus China gefunden.
Die China-Chinesen. Da sind sie.
Die sollen genauso
gut funktionieren wie das Original. Soll er
zuschlagen? Ja? Soll er?
Ich mein, die wollen
wahrscheinlich sagen, dass man das nicht sollte.
Aber ihr kennt mich.
Also, die richtige Antwort ist A.
Also, die Antwort, was die hören wollen, ist A.
Die richtige Antwort ist aber eigentlich
B. Jetzt könnte ich
meinen AliExpress
Affiliate-Code hier mal unter
die Leute bringen, den ich nicht besitze.
Also, gucken wir uns mal die Antworten an.
Nein.
Smart-Home-Geräte sollte man nur von seriösen
Herstellern bei vertrauenswürdigen Händlern kaufen.
Kopien aus China haben leider oft Mängel
in der Sicherheit oder in der Qualität. Also, ich kann euch
eins sagen. Smart-Home-Geräte,
wenn man nicht weiß, was die genau machen,
beziehungsweise Custom-Firma
vielleicht und sonst was, du weißt nie,
was die normalerweise, also was die
machen und du weißt auch nie, ob die Sicherheitsmängel
haben. Du kannst davon ausgehen, dass so ziemlich
90%
dieser, der normalen Smart-Home-Dinger,
die du dir daheim hinstellst, haben Sicherheitsprobleme.
Ich möchte nur mal daran erinnern, die ganzen,
die Leute, die Wise-Cams hatten,
da waren die Streams öffentlich über den
China-Chinesen-Server abrufbar.
So. Und dazu kommt,
selbst wenn ich mir jetzt hier bei Amazon.de
ein Gerät, sagen wir mal, von einem deutschen
Hersteller, nehmen wir mal Hammer
aus Bayern. Hammer.
Ja, wenn du da von denen eine Steckdosenleiste
kaufst, das ist exakt die gleiche
Steckdosenleiste, wie
von den China-Chinesen.
Das weiß ich, weil ich mir absichtlich
die Steckdosenleiste von Hammer gekauft
habe, weil es die baugleiche China-Chinesen-
Steckdosenleiste ist, wo ich Custom-Firma
drauf flashen kann, nur,
dass Hammer das glücklicherweise so gemacht hat,
eine uralte Firmware
drauf zu machen, sodass sie noch flashbar war.
So.
Also ja, er sollte zuschlagen,
die Technik ist ja die gleiche. Also,
Leute, es ist alles genauso sicher,
es ist davon überhaupt nichts sicher, wenn du nicht
selbst den Kram drauf machst. Okay,
wir nehmen die offizielle Antwort, aber
die eigentliche Antwort ist ja.
Teilprüfung abschließen. Bam.
Hone. Easy.
Huge. Easy.
Easy as fuck.
E-Easy as fuck.
Way to dank, genau.
So. Wir machen noch
eine weitere
für die Noobs.
Das kommt nämlich als nächstes.
Wir machen noch Internet für Noobs, Leute.
Den Rest machen wir dann für Profis, ja?
Aber das Internet für Noobs,
das müssen wir noch machen.
Wir machen noch mal das Internet für Noobs
und dann machen wir beruflich
Level 3. Bam.
Also, starten.
Jawoll.
Was bedeutet privater oder
anonymer Modus im Browser?
Das hängt ein bisschen
vom Browserhersteller ab.
Okay.
Ist dieser aktiviert, werden die
Webseiten, die ich mir angesehen habe,
nicht in einer Liste gespeichert.
Das wollen Sie wahrscheinlich hören,
wobei das so nicht ganz richtig ist.
Zum Beispiel hast du
im privaten Modus
Safari iOS
hast du einen extra
Private Tab und solange du den nicht
schließt, hast du eine Übersicht
der geöffneten Seiten und sowas in der Richtung.
Also, das wollen Sie wahrscheinlich hören,
ist aber nicht ganz richtig.
Ist dieser aktiviert, werden im Browser keine Passwörter
gespeichert, die ich auf Webseiten eingebe.
Es werden normalerweise eh keine
Passwörter gespeichert, die ich auf Webseiten eingebe.
Außer ich sage explizit.
Ist dieser aktiviert,
wird meine Webcam abgeschaltet.
Schaltet der private Modus die Webcam ab?
Nee, oder?
Ist dieser aktiviert, wird meine
IP-Adresse geändert, also die Nummer,
mit der sich meine Geräte
im Internet identifizieren und über
die HackerInnen, das ist ganz
wichtig an der Stelle,
auf meinen PC zugreifen können.
Es hängt vom Browserhersteller ab.
Normalerweise nicht,
aber wenn du sowas wie Opera verwendest,
mit China-Chinesen VPN,
die haben ja so Funktionen drin, also ich würde
es jetzt mal so lassen. Mal gucken, ob die
damit einverstanden sind.
Das ist kein Browser. Exploration.
Safari, Chrome, Firefox.
Okay, Exploration.
Herr Müller akzeptiert immer alle Cookies, wenn er
eine Webseite besucht. Welche Konsequenzen hat das?
Wahrscheinlich gar keine, wenn man ehrlich ist.
Es passiert nichts weiter, wenn der Anbieter,
was denn der Anbieter erfährt, nicht auf welchen
Unterseiten
Herr Müller sich wie lange
aufgehalten hat.
Was?
Ey.
Du hast
schon die Möglichkeit
zu tracken, prinzipiell
über irgendwelche JavaScript-Geschichten,
wie lange einer sich eine Seite anguckt,
aber, hä, da habe ich Cookies
aber überhaupt nichts zu tun.
Ist die Webseite ein Online-Shop und er hat
und hat er Waren in seinen Warenkorb gelegt,
kann er die Bestellung auch einen Tag später
abschicken, wenn sein Warenkorb
wird beim zweiten Besuch wiederhergestellt.
Ja, das kann man mit
Cookies machen.
Das geht, das kann man mit Cookies machen.
Das, das geht mit Cookies.
Das geht aber auch noch anders, aber das mit Cookies
geht das auch.
Herr Müller bekommt auf verschiedenen Websites zum Beispiel
im Suchmaschinen immer wieder Werbung angezeigt, die er zu
seiner letzten Bestellung im Online-Shop passen.
Ja, das muss auch nicht zwangsläufig über Cookies gemacht
sein, aber wahrscheinlich oder wie auch immer.
Yes, yes.
Also ich lasse es jetzt einfach mal.
So, das mit den Unterseiten, keine Ahnung.
Sie sind sehr vage, sehen nämlich an die Leute.
Ich muss mein Headset mal kurz entknoten.
Das hat Aussetzer, das sagt so, ich bin wieder da.
Okay, wir lassen es jetzt einfach so weiter.
Was ist keine Suchmaschine?
Firefox, Firefox, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt hätten sie mich fast
gebetet, fast, fast, wenn er gebetet raus gewesen.
Was kannst du mit deinem Browser machen?
Dateien und Ordner auf deiner Festplatte?
Testplatte sortieren im WWW auf Webseiten surfen?
Ja, das auf jeden Fall.
Dein Rechner auf Virenbefall prüfen?
Ja, aber das wollen die wahrscheinlich nicht hören.
Ich sage mal Virus total oder sowas.
Also ja, du kannst mit deinem Browser auch Rechner auf Virenbefall prüfen.
Aber das wollen sie wahrscheinlich nicht hören an der Stelle.
Den Verlauf deiner besuchten Webseiten löschen?
Ja, das kann ich auch mit einem Browser machen, wobei das eher nicht
so der Haupt Anwendungs Zweck eines Browsers ist.
Weiter Wo kannst du bei deinem Smartphone zwischen
WLAN und mobile Internet umschalten?
Ja, das kommt. Das hängt vom Smartphone ab.
Okay, wahrscheinlich das hier.
Wahrscheinlich. Aber das hängt ganz entscheidend vom Smartphone ab.
Das kannst du so, so universell nicht sagen.
Sollte ein Hersteller mal rausbringen ein Gerät, was Knöpfe dafür hat, dann geht das damit.
Also das ist so allgemein gültig.
Kann man das überhaupt nicht sagen? Weiter.
Welche Unternehmen betreiben Mobilfunknetze in Deutschland?
Telekom, Vodafone? Ja.
1&1, Gmx und Kongstar?
Nee, Kongstar ist Telekom, Saturn, Mediamarkt und Cyberport.
Naja, das ist Telekom, Vodafone.
O2.
Was ist mit Web 2.0, Leute?
Web 2.0 ist doch schon wieder.
Also das ist komplett outdated, Alter.
Web 2.0.
Wir sind Web 4.0.
Industrie 8.0.
Agile Horizontal-Diagonal-Skalierer.
Serverless.
Web.
NFT.
Was auch immer, aber 2.0 ist...
Also das Internet ist größer geworden, sodass nun mehr Inhalte hinein passen.
Alles klar.
Das Internet ist mit einem Update aktualisiert worden, sodass es nun sicherer ist.
Jeder Mensch kann im Internet Inhalte veröffentlichen...
What?
Was?
Was wollt ihr von mir wissen?
Äh...
Das letzte, oder?
Wahrscheinlich C.
Aber die...
Leute, mein Headset hat immer noch Aussetzer.
Wartet mal kurz, ich muss es mal kurz fixen.
Und ich muss euch muten, weil ansonsten fliegen euch die Ohren weg.
So, ich hoffe, es funzt alles.
Also wahrscheinlich wird er das wissen.
Okay.
Teilprüfung abschließen.
Und?
Was haben wir richtig?
Oh, Leute.
Wir haben Frage 1 verkackt.
Frage 1.
Fail.
Was bedeutet?
Privater, oder?
Okay.
Ja, meinetwegen.
Wie gesagt, normalerweise werden die Passwörter eh nur gespeichert, wenn du sagst, ich will
sie speichern.
Aber in Ordnung, lass ich mir gefallen.
So, jetzt upgraden wir.
Jetzt upgraden wir hier.
Beruflich Level 3.
Also richtig High IQ Modus jetzt aktiviert.
Business Class.
Jetzt wird es heikel.
Ja, hier.
Cisco Internet Professional.
Nein.
Wie heißt das?
Was heißt das?
Google Professional.
Nein.
Wie heißt das Ding?
Certified Cisco Internet Engineer?
Ne.
Wie heißt das, wie heißt das oberste von Cisco?
Network Professional.
Ne.
CCNA ist das unterste.
Das ist Associate.
Associate.
Das mein ich nicht.
Gut.
Also.
Brage.
Sonst ist die Kündigung direkt raus, wenn ich das jetzt verkacke.
Auf geht's.
Teilprüfung starten.
Level 3 beruflich.
Übrigens, wisst ihr, was mir aufgefallen ist?
Was diesen Test schon instant komplett useless macht?
Man kann cheaten nebenbei.
Niemand guckt zu.
Ich könnte einfach einen Tab aufmachen und nach der richtigen Antwort suchen.
Jetzt starten.
Okay.
Ubuntu.
Nein, nein, nein.
Sorry, Leute.
Wir wissen, ihr wisst genauso gut wie ich, dass das nicht Ubuntu heißt, sondern...
Sondern Jubantu.
Das verstörendste Video war ja immer noch mal auf YouTube, wo wir danach geguckt haben, wie das richtig heißt.
Da gab es ein Video von Nelson Mandela, der dann sagt Ubuntu.
Und irgendjemand hat dann das Ubuntu-Logo dazu gemacht.
Bloß mit dem Unterschied, Nelson Mandela hatte mit Ubuntu überhaupt gar nichts zu tun.
Das ist halt ein ganz normales südafrikanisches Wort.
Also, Ubuntu ist eine Distribution des Betriebssystems Linux.
Jawohl, weiter.
Oh, jetzt...
Jetzt wird es aber kompliziert.
Also, Herr Meier ist Administrator in seiner Firma und stellt fest, dass es für das auf allen Firmen-PCs laufende Betriebssystem Windows 7 keine Sicherheitsupdates mehr gibt.
Ja, erstmal direkt Kündigung schreiben.
Er bespricht dieses Sicherheitsproblem mit seiner Chefin und erhält von ihr den Auftrag, auf allen Rechnern in der Firma ein neues Betriebssystem zu installieren.
Seine Chefin möchte, dass das neue Betriebssystem Open Source ist.
Das halte ich für ein Gerücht.
Das halte ich aber für ein Gerücht, dass das eine Anforderung ist, die von der Chefin kommt.
Da habe ich meine Zweifel, dass das irgendeine Chef- bzw. Chefin sagen würde.
Seine Chefin möchte, dass das neue Betriebssystem Open Source ist.
Für welches wird er sich entscheiden?
Na, Android, logisch, oder?
Übrigens, in Chat, wir wissen alle, es heißt nicht Linux.
Korrekt, der Chat hat es wieder.
Ja.
I'd like to interject for a moment.
Was wir nämlich unter Linux verstehen, ist ja in Wirklichkeit eigentlich GNU-slash-Linux.
Lass es mal nicht Richard Stelman, wie spricht man den Typ überhaupt aus, Richard Stelman, sehen, dass da einfach nur Linux steht.
Das ist GNU-slash-Linux.
Spricht man das überhaupt GNU aus oder muss man das GNU oder so aussprechen?
GNU plus Linux?
Okay, Linux.
Ich meine, er könnte auch Android nehmen, wobei Android ist mit Open Source jetzt alles so weit her ist, ja.
Weiter.
Also, im Büro von Frau Meier ist das Netzwerk ausgefallen, ob LAN oder WLAN.
Nichts funktioniert mehr.
Sie fragt sich, ob sie übergangsweise den persönlichen Hotspot ihres privaten Handys aktivieren sollte, um über die LTE-Verbindung ihres Handys ihren Dienst-Laptop wieder mit dem Internet zu verbinden.
Ist das sicher?
Okay, was sagen sie dazu?
Nein.
Bei einem Hackerangriff wäre sowohl ihre privaten als auch ihre Laptops verbunden.
Ja, der Hotspot ist sicher, obwohl ihre privaten als auch ihre geschäftlichen Daten sind bei einem Hackerangriff nicht in Gefahr.
Hä?
Also, C.
Also, ich meine, die wollen wahrscheinlich A wissen.
Aber, also ich meine, wenn ihr den privaten Hotspot verwendet, dann ist ja nicht irgendwie die privaten Daten ihres Handys in Gefahr,
sondern im Zweifelsfall halt...
Was auch immer sie sich da einfängt auf ihrem Laptop, also auf ihrem Handy wird wahrscheinlich nichts passieren.
Aber wahrscheinlich wollen sie das wissen.
Was aber wenig Sinn ergibt.
Ja, das ist zu high IQ der Fragensteller gewesen.
Welche Vorteile haben Unternehmen, die auf das Betriebssystem Linux setzen?
Ich finde das gut.
Sehr viele Linux-bezogene Fragen.
Sehr nice.
Nicht dieser ganze Windows-Excel-Kack da immer.
Ordentliche Fragen.
Linux ist kostenfrei.
Das Unternehmen spart Geld.
Das wollen sie wahrscheinlich hören, ist aber falsch.
Das kommt ganz drauf an, was für einen Linux.
Wenn man einen Red Hat, ein richtig echtes Red Hat betreiben will, also auch mit offiziellen Updates, Servern und sonst was, da braucht man eine Subscription und das kostet Geld.
Du kannst einen Red Hat gar nicht wirklich betreiben, ein offizielles Red Hat gar nicht wirklich großartig, also nicht gescheit betreiben, ohne Geld zu bezahlen.
Linux ist weniger anfällig für Angriffe.
Das Unternehmen ist somit geschützter.
Okay, ja, wollen sie wahrscheinlich auch hören.
Es gibt Linux mehr Programme als für Mac und Windows.
Vor allem Unternehmen in der kreativen Branche profitieren.
Nein, das kann es nicht sein.
Aber wir sind uns ja einig, dieses Jahr ist das Jahr des Linux-Desktops, oder Chat?
Jetzt ist es soweit.
Ja, gut, seht ihr auch so.
Es ist für unerfahrene AnwenderInnen sehr einfach, Hardware bei Linux zu installieren.
AdministratorInnen können das im Kurs.
Das ist so ein schöner Fall von, es macht sich immer lesbarer, dann DoppelpunktInnen hintendran zu schreiben.
Ich meine, man weiß ja auch sowas gemeint ist.
Es ist für unerfahrene AnwenderInnen sehr einfach.
Nein, ist es nicht.
Je nachdem, doch, ist es.
Aber Hardware installieren können Administratoren auf jeden Fall nicht dem Anwender überlassen, auch nicht unter Windows.
Weil ein Anwender schraubt bestimmt nicht seinen Desktop in der Firma auf,
baut da irgendwie eine neue Netzwerke, oder was?
Ja, das ist so.
Das ist so.
Da kommt eine neue Netzwerkkarte ein und macht wieder zu.
Ja, die haben schon Probleme, ein USB-Stick richtig rum einzuklingen.
Achso, Vorteile.
Achso, nee, nee, dann muss das weg.
Gibt es überhaupt AdministratorInnen?
Ja, gibt es.
Wir haben sogar welche bei mir auf der Arbeit.
Also, mir fallen direkt aus dem Kopf drei Stück aus ganz unterschiedlichen Bereichen ein.
Wir haben eine bei, okay, iOS-Anwendungsentwicklung haben wir jede Menge.
Zeit.
Scheiß drauf.
iOS-Anwendungsentwicklung haben wir jede Menge, aber das zählt nicht.
Windows-Active Directory-Administratorin fällt mir eine ein.
Datenbank-Admin fällt mir eine ein.
Und Software-Tests und Entwicklung fällt mir eine ein.
Also, da haben wir durchaus einige.
So, weiter.
Herr Krachmeier ist der IT-Sicherheitsbeauftragte in seiner Firma.
Er soll für die Büros einen Sprachassistenten anschaffen.
Er findet ein Gerät, das alle Anfragen in den USBs...
Ah, speichert.
Ich meine, besser als in Russland.
Oder besser als in China.
Und eins, das alle Anfragen in Irland speichert.
Welches ist sicher?
Was?
Welches ist sichert?
Das sollte er eigentlich wissen als Sicherheitsbeauftragter, oder?
Warum müssen wir ihm das sagen?
Das Gerät, das alle Anfragen in Irland speichert.
Ja, das ist richtig.
Letztendlich ist das Beste, was man an der Stelle aber machen kann,
sich nicht darauf zu verlassen, wo der ganze Mist gespeichert wird.
Und dass es in der EU ist.
Und sich auch, ja, alle dran halten und sowas.
Weil im Zweifelsfall ist das eh alles Scheiß.
Schall und Rauch.
Es ist wichtig, dass du den Kram am besten verschlüsselt ablegst.
Weil dann kann auch keiner was damit unfugtreiben.
So, weiter.
Trage das fehlende Wort ein.
Hat man auf einem Rechner keine Rechte, Programme selbst zu installieren,
kann man auf Versionen von Programmen zurückgreifen.
Lokale?
Oder...
Was wollen die?
Ah, sie erfordern keine Installation.
Ähm...
Oh, wie nennt man das nochmal?
Äh, uuuh...
Ja, Portable, ne?
Portable.
Ich glaube, ihr habt das richtig geschrieben.
Streamer, read Chat.
Ich musste das nur verschleiern, als ich den Chat gelesen habe.
So, weiter.
Tragen Sie die fehlenden Wörter ein.
Möchte man unterwegs mit dem Laptop ins Internet gehen
und soll dabei das Tablet oder das Smartphone die Rolle des Routers übernehmen,
so muss man in den Einstellungen ein...
Äh, Hotspot...
Hotspot.
Einrichten.
Das haben die uns doch vorher sogar schon gefragt.
Weiter.
Herr Demir, schau mal da.
Der ist aber aktiv.
Äh, hat eine...
Moment, das...
Se...
Sekunde.
Das...
Das kennen wir schon.
Level 3?
Warum ist Level 3 beruflich die Frage für die Privat-Level-1-Oma drinne?
Skamast, Alter.
Ähm...
Achso, das ist jetzt Multiple-Choice.
Das ist jetzt Multiple-Choice.
Mehr Antworten.
Also, äh, dieser Fall brecht auf das Adressbuch im Smartphone zuzugreifen.
Sollte er der App die brechen?
Nein.
Nein, die Wetter-App braucht keine Kontaktdaten.
So, so würde ich mal...
Ich meine...
Wozu brauchst du...
Ich meine, das kommt auf die Wetter-App an.
Wenn die Wetter-App irgendwie, ähm, Sachen hat wie, äh, zu meinem Termin heute Mittag mit dem Max,
wie wird das Wetter an seinem Standort?
Dann ja, aber es kommt auf die App an.
So, Teilprüfung abschließen.
100%!
Huge, Leute.
Doch keine Abmahnung.
Easy.
Alles klar.
Weitere Teilprüfung starten.
Internet.
Jetzt wird's ernst.
Oder wie mein Opa sagen würde, jetzt wird's haarig.
Okay.
Trage die fehlenden Wörter ein.
Web-Tools zur Verwaltung von Inhalten auf Webseiten nennt man...
Was?
Äh, Content-Management-Systeme.
Wie schreibt man Management?
Ich schreibe Management immer falsch.
Content-Management-Systeme.
Ja, weiter.
Herr Müller surft im Büro mit seinem Browser auf dem Dienst-PCM.
Kognitiv.
Was der so alles macht.
Was bedeutet das?
Herr Müller?
Herr Müllers PC speichert keine Cookies.
Ja.
Herr Müllers PC speichert alle Cookies außer Werbekookies?
Nee.
Weiter.
Videoanrufe oder Messenger-Calls belasten auf Dienstreisen das...
Den Akku?
Ach, das Datenvolumen.
Meine Güte.
Das Klima.
Das Firmenkonto.
Ja, das ist doch wirklich eine sehr vage Frage, ja.
Ich meine, woher soll ich wissen, dass der Typ kein WLAN hat?
Das Gehirn belasten die auch, ja, das ist richtig.
Es belastet die Leute, wenn er öffentlich telefoniert im Zug.
Das Daten...
Wir schreiben einfach Datenvolumen.
Welche Potenziale bietet der neue Mobilfunkstandard 5G-Unternehmen und Organisationen?
Ja.
Ähm, niedrige Latenzzeiten für die verzerrungsfreie Kommunikation.
Was ist denn eine verzerrungsfreie Kommunikation?
In Videokonferenzen oder beim Livestreaming von Online-Produkt-Präsentationen?
Okay.
Bestimmt, das wollen die wahrscheinlich hören.
Übertragungsraten mit bis zu 10 oder sogar 20 Gigabits.
Ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung, wie schnell 5G ist.
Aber 10 Gigabit?
10 Gigabit erscheint mir etwas unrealistisch zu sein, dass man das auch in der Praxis erreicht.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, ob das theoretisch damit geworben wird, dass das maximal möglich wäre.
Also 100 ist auf jeden Fall zu viel.
Hohe Latenzzeiten für die verzerrungsfreie Kommunikation...
Nein.
Ja, weiter.
Herr Meier ist Redaktionsleiter bei einem Verlag und möchte, dass seine Online-Redaktion zukünftig
ein proprietäres Content-Management...
Sag mal, ist das Absicht, dass die ihre Antworten sich immer selbst geben?
Ein paar Fragen hintendran.
Was meint er?
Moment, was?
Dass sein Online-Redaktion künftig ein proprietäres Content-Management-System los...
Warum möchte denn der Verlag das, dass es ein proprietäres Content-Management-System ist?
Das ist halt komplett aus der Luft gegriffen.
Aber okay.
Was meint er?
Das CMS ist Quell-Offline.
Das CMS ist herstellergebunden.
Wird das so vom Hersteller beistellt, die Einsicht...
Ja.
Das meint er.
Trage die fehlenden Wörter ein.
Serpa ist die Abkürzung für...
Response-Page?
Response-Page oder sowas?
Leute, ich zeig euch jetzt, ich zeig euch jetzt, warum dieser Test komplett für den Arsch ist.
Search Engine Results-Page.
Easy as fuck.
So.
Easy clap.
Accregal.
Ähm, mit welchen Technologien kannst du im Homeoffice oder im Büro...
Anonymer im Netz surfen?
Proxy-Server?
VPN-Tunnel?
Was nochmal?
Mit welchen Technologien kannst du im Homeoffice oder im Büro anonymer...
Okay.
Homeoffice und Büro.
Das kommt drauf an, was geblockt ist und was nicht.
Theoretisch können da alle vier dazu beitragen.
Auch, auch nen...
Anony...
Es geht anonymer.
Ja.
Es gibt auch DNS-Server, die sagen...
Die so nach dem Motto, wir machen keine Aufzeichnung und sonst nix.
Wahrscheinlich ist DNS aus deren Sicht falsch.
Streng genommen ist DNS aber richtig bei dieser Fragestellung.
Welche Mobilfunkstandard gibt es nicht?
Äh, 6G.
Oh, wir sind schon durch.
Mal gucken.
Wir gucken...
Was ich hab...
Äh, statt Result, Result-Page geschrieben.
Mal gucken, was er sagt.
Teilprüfung abschließen.
Oh, Leute.
Wir haben verkackt.
Oh, tatsächlich.
5G?
Das macht in der Praxis im Leben keine 10 Gigabit.
Im Leben nicht.
Ich mein, das sagt vielleicht die maximale theoretisch mögliche...
Dings in der Spezifikation oder so sagen vielleicht 10 Gigabit.
Aber doch ganz bestimmt nicht in der Praxis.
Ja, Kündigung wird schon geschrieben.
Okay, das haben wir falsch gemacht und...
DNS-Server.
Wir haben es schon vermutet.
Aber DNS-Server ist richtig.
Weitere Prüfung starten.
Kommunikation.
Next.
Welche nützlichen Funktionen haben Programme wie MetaMouse, Slack oder MS Teams für Unternehmen?
Teilen von Präsentationen...
Mein Headset, Leute.
Das macht mich verrückt heute.
Warum?
Warum geht das immer aus zwischendurch?
Ganz ätzend.
Ähm...
Weiß auch nicht, was da los ist.
Okay.
Versand, Empfang von Chatnachrichten, Videoanruf oder Versand von...
Ja, Empfang und Versand von Verschlüssen.
Nein, Abonnieren von...
Ich hab keine Ahnung, ob dieser eines dieser drei Dinger nicht auch RSS-Feeds abonnieren kann.
Popschutz.
Ich hab den Schwamm hier liegen, Leute.
Ich hab den Schwamm für den Popschutz hier liegen.
Wir schneiden dem demnächst aus.
So, können Unternehmen ihren Kundenservice, zum Beispiel Bestellung bei Lieferdiensten,
regelmäßige Newsletter oder Infos auch per Messenger anbieten?
Warum?
Warum nicht?
Warum sollen sie das nicht...
Es ist natürlich vielleicht nicht die schönste...
Bestimmt.
Warum nicht?
Nein, Messenger sind nur den privaten Verbrauch zugesehen...
Vorgesehen.
Nur große Konzerne können diesen Service nutzen.
Kleine und Mittelstände oder Schwachsinn.
Ja, jedes Unternehmen kann in Messenger einen Unternehmensaccount einrichten und so ihren Kunden ins Service...
Hä?
Was ist das für eine Bescheu?
Das erinnert mich an die IHK-Abschlussprüfung.
Die wollen was?
Wahrscheinlich C hören, aber das kommt auf den Messenger an.
Ich kann mir auch einen Jabber-Account installieren irgendwo.
Jabber-Account anlegen.
Kennt noch einer Jabber?
Xamp?
Ne, nicht Xamp.
Ne, was ist die Abkürzung von Jabber?
Doch, Xamp, oder?
Kennt noch jemand einen Jabber?
Oh, weiter.
Jell dir vor, du bist Politiker im...
Einer Fraktion im Bundestag.
Sie bekommst...
Mit...
Wer hat diese Fragen geschrieben?
Dass deine persönliche Assistentin, weil sie für dich arbeitet, in sozialen Netzwerken sexistisch beleidigt wird.
Anzeige. Direkt.
Dann ist vorbei.
Ich empfehle ihr, sich im Internet zurückzuhalten und keine Beiträge mehr zu veröffentlichen.
Es kommt drauf an, was sie so schreibt?
Äh...
Das kommt drauf an.
Äh, ich empfehle ihr, ihre Social-Media-Accounts zu löschen.
Nö, das will ich auf gar keinen Fall machen.
Ich empfehle ihr, sich bei Organisationen wie HateAid oder Weißer Ring...
Oh, weiter.
Heißt das wirklich, Weißer Ring?
Das ist ja auch schon wieder grenzwertig.
Fast so schlimm wie Masterbranch.
So, ich empfehle ihr, sich bei...
Wahrscheinlich wollen sie das hören.
Ich empfehle ihr, die Hater persönlich anzukre...
Ja, ja.
Immer.
Immer zurückflamen.
Aber das meinen die wahrscheinlich nicht.
Das meinen die wahrscheinlich nicht.
Immer zurückflamen.
Und das Beste ist, das Beste ist...
Zurückflamen...
Und dann bannen.
Weil dann sind sie richtig abgefuckt.
Also, ich glaube, ich habe Erfahrung mit sowas.
Gerade auch durch YouTube und sonst was.
Wenn du Leute richtig abfucken willst, du antwortest denen...
Und schreibst was auch immer.
Und dann bannst du sie.
Und dann haben sie keine Möglichkeit zu antworten.
Und das fuckt die sowas von ab.
Da sind die richtig stinkig danach.
Ich habe sogar schon E-Mails gekriegt.
Weil ich Leute gebannt habe.
Okay.
Also, ich empfehle ihr...
Ich empfehle ihr, die Hater persönlich anzukre...
Das würde...
Ganz ehrlich?
Ja, aber wahrscheinlich wollen sie das nicht hören.
Ich bitte die gesamte Fraktion der Assistentin beizustehen und ihre Unterstützung anz...
Die gesamte Fraktion ist klar.
Ich hänge das erstmal an die große Glocke.
Ja?
Das ist ja bescheuert.
Ich stelle mich im Netz.
Ich stelle mich im Netz schützend vor meiner Assistentin und biete ihr Hilfe an.
Das kommt auf den Einzelfall an.
Das wollen sie wahrscheinlich auch hören.
So.
Und...
Ganz ehrlich, das Erste hängt ganz entscheidend davon ab, was sie so schreibt und was das für Hintergründe hat.
Ja?
Wenn die auf Twitter geht und keine Ahnung...
Ähm...
All men are trash oder irgendwie so Zeug schreibt.
Na gut, dann erwartest du ja oftmals schon irgendeine gewisse Reaktion.
Oder...
Keine Ahnung.
Wenn sie unter...
Ähm...
Kurz gesagt Videos auf YouTube...
Ihr Onlyfans-Profil postet als Werbung.
Da muss man sich über Beleidigung auch nicht wundern.
Also es kommt auf den Einzelfall an.
Die Zeit läuft ab.
Oh nein.
Aber wenn ich Politiker bin, müsste ich das eigentlich ignorieren, ja?
Okay, weiter.
Weiter.
Ich lass das jetzt einfach mal so.
Trag das fehlende Wort ein.
Das Team von Frau Meier plant eine Videokonferenz zur Präsentation zwei neuer...
Moment, der Satz ist gut.
Zweier neuen Produ...
Der Satz stimmt irgendwie nicht.
Oder von zwei...
neuen Produkten. Oder
zweier neuen Produkten.
Die Teilnehmenden der Videokonferenz
können am Ende der Präsentation
in zwei verschiedene
Chatrooms wahrscheinlich
Chatrooms gehen und fragen,
was wir hier in der Produktion
das Breakout
Was soll ja ein Breakout sein?
Weiter.
Frau Meier bietet in ihrer Firma
eine Videokonferenz zur Präsentation
Frau Meier ist ganz schön umtriebig, oder?
Frau Meier bietet in ihrer Firma
eine Videokonferenz zur Präsentation
des neuen Geschäftsberichts. Leider sind
viele Teilnehmer krank. Oh.
Monka Corona.
Sie schlägt vor,
die Präsentation mitsamt der Beiträge
aller Anwesenden aufzuzeichnen. Oh.
DSGVO.
Wir haben irgendwo ein DSGVO-E-Mode,
Leute. Toss. Toss.
DSGVO. Ganz, ganz
schlimm.
Sie schlägt vor,
die Präsentation aufzuzeichnen und
die Videodatei den kranken Teilnehmern zu
Darf sie das? Nein.
Achso.
Da bin ich mir gar nicht sicher, ehrlich gesagt.
Ne, Moment, Moment.
Äh.
Ich wollte nicht B, ich wollte C sagen.
Ja, wenn sie zuvor die Zustimmung
aller Anwesenden einholt.
Wahrscheinlich. Die Sache ist nur die,
ich glaube bei der DSGVO
ist sich keiner so sicher.
Ob und wie was genau geregelt.
Ich würde sagen C.
Der fiktive E-Mail-Provider
Mailix
stammt aus den USA.
Defektive E-Mail-Provider
Fastix aus Irland. Welcher wäre für die
NutzerInnen aus Deutschland rechtlich sicher?
Ja, ja, Fastix. Haben wir jetzt ja schon öfters hier gelernt.
Schon wieder Frau Müller.
Sendet ihrem Kollegen Herr Meier eine vertrauliche
Rechnung per E-Mail.
Diese besteht auf einer
End-zu-End-Verschlüsselung. Was meint er?
Ja, da hat er recht. Der Herr Meier ist
gut, der hat eine Ahnung, wovon er spricht.
Bei der Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung,
wird zwar die E-Mail mitsamt der vertraulichen Rechnung
verschlüsselt, versendet, aber unverschlüsselt
im Klartext auf Syrien.
Tja.
Das kommt drauf an.
Normalerweise bedeutet Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung,
dass es unterwegs
von keinem, der das abgreift,
gelesen werden kann.
Aber
war es nicht so, dass
bei D-E-Mail oder
bei Postings-Mail
es nicht eine Hintertür
gab bei der Verschlüsselung?
Weil davon absteht, den Scheiß verwendet eh keiner.
Äh, okay.
Also muss es das sein.
Okay, was sind präventive Schutzmaßnahmen
gegen digitale Belästigungen im Internet?
Die machen sich alle wahnsinnig
Gedanken über irgendwelche
Hate-Speech-Geschichten und sowas, oder?
Ich meine, ich bin jetzt seit
auf YouTube und sonst was.
Und ich hab mich schon oft
mit irgendwelchen richtig
saudummen Kack...
Was weiß ich?
Ultra-nerving-Leuten halt.
Ich muss jetzt ja nicht mehr beleidigen, als sein muss.
Auseinandersetzen müssen.
Also mehr als wahrscheinlich
99% der Leute
je in ihrem Leben
machen müssen.
Aber
so viel Gedanken um irgendwie Hate-Speech mache ich mir auch nicht.
Okay, was sind präventive
Schutzmaßnahmen gegen die digitale Belästigung?
Oh nein! Time!
In sozialen Netzwerken keine persönliche Informationen.
Jawohl!
In sozialen Netzwerken keine Freundschaftsverfragung.
Nein, nein, Kinder!
Kinder und die...
Aufklären!
Beide...
Abschließen!
Easy!
Die letzte Frage haben wir richtig beantwortet.
So, was haben wir denn falsch?
Ähm...
Moment, was?
Was?
Wollt ihr mich verarschen?
Ich bitte die gesamte Fraktion der Assistenten beizuschienen,
ihre Unterstützung anzubieten.
Ernsthaft?
Man soll, weil irgend...
Also.
Vielleicht möchte die das doch gar nicht, dass das Gott um die Welt mitkriegt.
Ich meine, stell dir mal vor.
Du bist im Internet, flamest dich da mit Leuten,
wirst vielleicht sogar noch sexistisch beleidigt,
irgendwelche Leute posten abartige Bilder und sonst was.
Möchte man wirklich, dass das jeder erfährt?
What?
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Außerdem, was soll denn die gesamte Fraktion da machen?
Also, ich meine, wenn die sagt, so nach dem Motto, ich komme damit alleine nicht klar, ich brauche Hilfe,
ey, kann man sich das alles überlegen, aber man sollte doch nicht von sich aus die gesamte Fraktion da...
Das ist doch bescheuert.
Wahrscheinlich ist die Fraktion sogar selbst daran beteiligt, irgendwelche Typen in der hinteren Reihe oder so.
Okay, was habe ich noch falsch gemacht?
Okay.
Was ist daran falsch?
Wo steht denn was Richtiges?
Chat ist falsch, okay.
Breakout Room?
Das habe ich noch nie gehört.
Noch nie.
Wirklich, keine Ahnung, was ein Breakout Room ist.
Datenwelt, Gefahrenschutz...
Wir machen noch eine.
Komm, Leute, wir machen noch eine.
Wir machen noch Technologie Alltag.
Danach gucken wir noch ein paar Videos, ich muss was trinken.
Gibt es in Deutschland einen digitalen Personalausweis?
Äh.
Ja, ja, ich glaube schon.
Habe ich noch nie verwendet.
Ich glaube, den gibt es.
Das war so ein Versuch, der sich nie durchgesetzt hat.
Ähm, ja, doch, ich glaube, den gibt es.
Ich glaube, den gibt es.
Ähm, weiter.
Was kann ein Unternehmen tun, wenn das Opfer eines Betrugs bei einem Fake-Shop geworden ist?
Ja, erst mal gucken, welcher Depp da bestellt hat und wer unfähig ist, das zu erkennen.
Aber, okay, Polizeiverstände, Anzeige wegen Betrugs...
Kann man immer machen, egal, ob es online war oder nicht, wenn du gescampt wurdest.
Screenshots von der Bestellung ist sicherlich auch nicht verkehrt.
Bankbenachrichtigen, ja, ist es auch sinnvoll, wenn man Geld zurückbuchen möchte.
Ja?
Kann man alle drei sagen?
Screenshots von der Bestellung machen, wenn der Shop schon ein bisschen shady, scam-mäßig aussieht.
Warum nicht?
Ist ja auch nicht verkehrt, alle drei.
So.
Welche der Maßnahmen...
Können Bestandteile des digitalen Detox sein?
Was für ein Ding.
Ich glaube, das ist nix für mich als 15 Stunden am Tag vorm Rechnerhocker.
Ich weiß nicht mal, was das sein soll.
Detox heißt entgiften.
Also, digitales Entgiften.
Was ist denn der Unterschied zwischen dem Bahnmodus und dem Flugzeugmodus?
Man darf auch nicht sagen, dass es den Bahnmodus nicht gibt.
Im Bahnmodus ist es eh kein Problem.
Weil die Bahn...
Die Bahn ist eh nicht da.
Du kannst im Freien stehen bleiben, ohne alles.
Okay.
Smartphone in den Bahnmodus schalten.
Berechtigungen deaktivieren.
Ich weiß überhaupt nicht, was die von mir wollen.
Bahn hat keinen Empfang.
In den Flugzeugmodus schalten.
Benachrichtigungen deaktivieren.
Ich rate jetzt mal.
Ich hab keinen Schimmer, was die von mir wollen.
Frau...
Alu Nathan.
Möchte die alten Büromöbel ihrer Firma bei Ebay verkaufen.
Die Firma hat aber gar keinen Ebay Account.
Sie hat zwei Möglichkeiten.
Sie legt einen Account für die Firma oder sie verkauft die Schüler über ihren privaten Account.
Was ist hinsichtlich des Datenschutzes sicherer?
Sie sollte einen Account für ihre Firma legen, so schützt sie ihren privaten Account.
Naja, also ganz ehrlich, ähm, wenn ich was für die Firma verkaufe...
Wenn ich jetzt immer mit einen Firmen Account mache, ich würde das garantiert nicht über meinen privaten Account machen.
Außer ich muss meinen natürlichen Privataccount haben.
Außer ich muss meinen Privataccount anmaßen.
Außer ich bin ein super agiles Berliner Startup oder so.
Da weiß man ja nie.
Aber wahrscheinlich will die Büromöbel da eh keiner haben.
Next.
Was sollte man beim Online-Banking beachten?
Das Zugangspasswort sollte sicher sein.
Aus kleinen, Großbuchstaben, Sonderzeichen und Zahlen bestehen.
Das stimmt nicht.
Das wollen die hören, aber das stimmt nicht.
Das Wichtigste ist ein langes Passwort.
Länge ist deutlich wichtiger als ein großer Zeichenvorrat.
Es muss lang sein.
Man sollte ein Zahlungslimit einrichten, um vor dem Abheben hoher Summen durch Betrüger zu schützen.
Äh, ein Zahlungslimit.
Kann man auch machen.
Wenn es sowas gibt, warum nicht?
Man sollte das Online-Banking nicht nachts nutzen.
Da sind die Betrüger aktiv.
Ja, vor allem die China-Chinese in der anderen Zeitzone.
Die sind da.
Das war immer ganz, ganz gefährlich nachts.
So, lassen wir das mal so.
Aber wie gesagt, das mit dem Passwort stimmt nicht.
Das Passwort muss lang sein.
Denn nachts ist kälter als draußen.
Wisst ihr doch.
Weiter.
Der Herr Meier schon wieder.
Arbeitet am Tag am PC.
Nach dem Feierabend schneidet er zu Hause am Schreibtisch Videos für YouTube.
Richtig krasser Content-Creator, der Herr Meier.
Eines Tages klagt er über Rücken- und Kopfschmerzen.
Was geht?
Was kann er tun, um zukünftig solche Schmerzen zu verhindern?
Einen Stuhl mit Armstütze anschaffen, mit Armlehnen.
Das ist das Allerwichtigste, aber das steht da wahrscheinlich nicht.
Er sollte mit geradem Rücken und Schultern arbeiten, beziehungsweise Video schreiben.
Das möchten die hören, ist jetzt, man muss vielleicht nicht da hören, wie der letzte Penner so.
Aber man muss jetzt auch nicht die ganze Zeit kerzen.
Gerade wichtig ist, dass man, dass man.
Die Ärmel ablegen kann.
Das ist richtig.
Und jetzt übrigens mal alle reinzappen beim Herr Meier gleich.
Er sollte zum Ausgleich Sport treiben, zum Beispiel.
Ja, das ist richtig.
Er sollte mehr trinken.
Das ist auch.
Er sollte sich einen Massagestuhl kaufen.
Ja, das.
Also.
Das ist jetzt eine doofe Antwort.
Ja, das kann durchaus sein, dass es was bringt.
Aber pauschal würde ich das nicht so sagen.
Mehr trinken ist auf jeden Fall auch sinnvoll.
Jetzt wieder.
Drei Massagen.
Happy End.
Es war klar, dass der Chainlock mit irgendwie sowas um die Ecke kommt wieder.
Egal.
Weiter.
So, Frau Meier.
Arbeitet jeden Tag und am Wochenende sehr lange.
Nach ihrem Feierabend haben in ihrer kleinen Stadt immer alle Supermärkte zu.
Was kann sie tun?
Krass.
Jeden Tag und am Wochenende.
Die ist bestimmt Consultant, Frau Meier.
Sie muss Excel-Dateien copy-pasten.
Sie kann während der.
Sie soll in Frankfurt.
Okay.
Sie kann während der Arbeit im Supermarkt anrufen, frische Lebensmittel bestellen, die danach.
Ja, das geht.
Sie kann frische Lebensmittel online bestellen, nach Feierabend zu nach.
Moment.
Das geht beides.
Das geht auch beides.
Sie kann während der Arbeit im Supermarkt anrufen, dass keine Ahnung, ob diesen Service im Supermarkt anbietet.
Sollte ein Supermarkt diesen Service anbieten, dann geht das.
Okay, ihr habt recht.
Wenn, wenn der Punkt ist anrufen, dann ist es.
B, dann ist es B, Bestellung per Fax wäre auch noch was weiter.
Was bedeutet der Begriff Smart ID?
Keine Ahnung.
Dank des Smart ID Gesetzes kann jeder, kann jeder Bürger in mit einer ID mit einer Identifikation, so was ich in Onlineshops einkaufen.
Dank des Smart ID Gesetzes kann jeder jeder Bürger in den Personal.
Was?
Das ist auch online als Ausweis.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Wahrscheinlich B, ja.
Weil ich meine, irgendwie online, Online Shopping kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Habe ich noch nie gesehen in der Richtung.
Ich kaufe viel online.
Muss B sein.
Macht aber wahrscheinlich keiner.
Teilprüfung abschließen.
100 Prozent.
Leute.
Absolut Next Level Shit hier.
Five Headings da, Five Head.
Weitere Prüfung starten.
Sollen wir die anderen zwei?
Noch schnell durchklicken, dass wir dann uns am Ende des das Zertifikat mal angucken können.
Wir machen, wir machen das jetzt, sage ich.
Okay, Datenwelt Daten.
Ich mache, ich mache mir da ich.
Ich mache jetzt da echt mal einen Witz draus.
Ich drücke mir das.
Ich speichere mir das Zertifikat als PDF und morgen schicke ich das in Teams an mein Chef.
Einfach mal Just for Fun.
Guck mal hier für die nächste Gehaltsverhandlung.
Okay, trage die fehlenden Wörter oder die fehlenden Buchstaben ein.
Nutzen Unternehmen Software in einer Cloud spricht man von Software as a Service.
Wobei das gar nicht mal sein muss.
Das stimmt ja nicht, was da steht.
Das muss nicht, das muss nicht zwangsläufig sein.
Aber wahrscheinlich ist es Software as a Service.
Weiter.
Trage die fehlenden Passwörter ein.
Endpass Last Nordpass.
Sind Passwort Manager Nordpass.
Ja, die Geschichte mit NordVPN habe ich euch ja schon zweimal erzählt.
Ich muss mal kurz in meine E-Mails gucken, ob die nochmal geantwortet haben.
NordVPN wollte ja, dass ich mein, mein VPN kritisches Video lösche, dass sie zu einer Kooperation bereit sind.
Da habe ich, das mache ich nicht.
Gucken, ob es was Neues gibt.
Sekunde, ich schaue mal kurz rein.
Auszahlungsvergütung.
Ah, das lese ich natürlich immer gerne.
Umfrage.
Was?
Ihh, ich kriege wieder G2A Werbung.
Monka S.
Geh weg.
Okay, schnell.
Also, weiter.
Herr Demir vertritt seine Kollegin Frau Schmidt auf einem Messestand seiner Firma.
Ein Interessent meldet sich und möchte mit der Firma Kontakt aufnehmen.
Leider sind Herr Demirs Visitenkarten alle.
Feels Batman.
Visitenkarten.
Das ist ja schon richtig Boomer-Style, oder?
Okay, darf er die Visitenkarte von Frau Schmidt verteilen?
Ja, wenn Frau Schmidt der Weitergabe ihrer persönlichen Kontaktdaten an Interessenten zugeschrieben hat.
Ja.
Herr Yilmaz meint, meine Daten sind synchronisiert worden.
Was meint er?
Wahrscheinlich weiß er nicht, wovon er spricht.
Deswegen können wir das eigentlich überspringen.
Die Daten, die er meint, sind auf der internen und externen Festplatte gleichzeitig geöffnet worden.
Die Daten nehmen wir jetzt einfach auf intern und extern auf dem gleichen Stand.
Wahrscheinlich meint er das, ja.
Wobei, also, das ist egal.
Er weiß, wie gesagt, er weiß nicht, wovon er spricht.
Der Herr Krallmeier ist wieder am Start, sagt zu seinem Kollegen, Verstöße gegen den Datenschutz können Unternehmen bis zu 20 Millionen Euro Strafgeld kosten.
Hat er recht?
Keine Ahnung, was in der DSGVO als Höchststrafe drinsteht.
Ja, das wäre in der Regel, sind die Bußgelder viel niedriger.
Okay.
Ja, die Datenschutzbörse kann aber von der Strafe absehen, wenn der Datenschutzverschluss schnell beruht.
Wahrscheinlich auch.
Nein, so hoch darf die Strafe...
Nein, es gibt kein Geld.
Wahrscheinlich A und B, oder?
Chat, was meint ihr?
Wahrscheinlich A und B.
Passt.
Nur A?
Warum ist, warum nur A?
Kann er nicht davon absehen?
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wenn ich ehrlich bin.
Warum sollen die davon absehen?
Was weiß ich?
Ich frage jetzt, ob sie es können oder nicht.
Egal, wir lassen das jetzt so.
Ralf bekommt nach dem Login in seinem...
Die haben es nicht mit richtig deutschen Sätzen.
Ich meine, ich schreibe auch viel Mist.
Aber wenn das ein offizieller Webauftritt ist, wer hat denn das geschrieben?
Haben sie das irgendwie über Pfeiffer in Indien outgesourced, oder was?
Ralf bekommt nach dem Login in seinen Online-Shop eine SMS mit einem Code,
an sein Smartphone gesendet.
Mit dem Code soll er den Login bestätigen.
Er hat die Zwei-Faktor-Authentisierung.
Zwei-Faktor-Authentisierung.
Schreibt man das in Deutsch so?
Authentisierung.
Tatsächlich.
Das müsste aber eigentlich eine Autorisierung sein.
Oder eine...
Nee, es müsste eine Authentifizierung...
Authentifizierung sein, weil der Unterschied dazwischen den beiden ist,
das eine bedeutet, ob du rein darfst,
das andere bedeutet, was du dann danach darfst, wenn du drinnen bist.
Das ist der Unterschied zwischen Authentifizierung und Autorisierung.
Zwei, nicht zwei?
Da bin ich mal gespannt, ob die das hinkriegen, wenn man da zwei...
Da bin ich mal gespannt, wenn man da zwei reinschreibt.
Dürfen ArbeitnehmerInnen nach einer Kündigung von ihrem ArbeitgeberInnen...
Moment, Alter, muss man Arbeitgeber ernsthaft gendern?
Ich meine, ArbeitnehmerInnen verstehe ich ja noch irgendwie,
aber von ihrem Arbeitgeber?
Das ist doch schon so ein abstraktes Ding
und bezieht sich halt meistens noch nicht mehr auf eine echte Person,
sondern eben halt auf das Unternehmen.
Das Unternehmen ist ja der Arbeitgeber.
Und nicht irgendwie...
Eine Person.
Naja.
Dass ihre personenbezogenen Daten im Unternehmen gelöscht werden.
Ja.
Ja, ich denke mal schon.
Ich meine, die erste Antwort ist so bescheuert.
Das kann eigentlich nicht sein.
Ja, oder?
Ich denke, dass das passt.
Ich finde das geil.
Da sagst du, machst du dich einmal über die Geschichte lustig,
schon kommen sie im Chat die Leute an und sagen,
ja, Maxi, ha, ha, ha, null, fick die Scheiße.
Die Sache ist, wie immer, nicht schwarz und weiß.
Aber das ist, es ist ja klar, so ist das halt im Chat.
Das ist nicht, das ist, wie viel ist nicht schwarz und weiß?
Und wisst ihr, warum?
Ich persönlich bin ja der Meinung,
die ganzen Diskussionen über Gendern und Nicht-Gendern
sind komplett heiße Luft und eigentlich komplett verschwendetes Geld,
äh, Geld auch, verschwendete Zeit.
Wisst ihr, warum da so viel drüber diskutiert wird?
Also ich bin der Meinung,
das wird sich entweder durchsetzen oder nicht.
Wenn es einen sinnvollen Mehrwert bietet,
dann ist das nicht so.
Und die Leute davon überzeugt mit der Zeit.
Wenn sich das durchsetzen,
übers Knie brechen,
kannst du nichts.
Aber wisst ihr, warum da so viele Leute
wahnsinnig emotional und
aufgeheizt drüber diskutieren?
Das liegt einzig und allein daran,
weil es ein,
wie soll ich sagen,
ein simples Thema ist,
wo jeder
irgendeine Meinung dazu hat,
die er kundtun will.
Ja, das ist jetzt keine Raketen,
das ist eigentlich ein ziemlich überschaubares,
simples Themengebiet,
wo man, wo jeder meint,
was dazu sagen zu müssen.
Und jeder, jeder ist der Meinung,
ja, muss sein,
die anderen sagen, nein, darf auf gar keinen Fall sein.
Und eigentlich lenkt das
von deutlich wichtigeren Problemen ab,
die man hat,
worüber sich die Leute sich vielleicht mal Gedanken machen sollten.
Ansonsten, mir ist das vollkommen egal.
Ich finde es an manchen Stellen sehr unglücklich lesbar,
aber ich finde es auch sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr.
Gerade wenn man sich noch nicht einmal
sich darauf geeinigt hat,
wie man es denn jetzt macht.
Mit Doppelpunkt, mit Unterstrichen, mit Kronos im I,
mit kleinem I, mit Sternchen,
auseinandergeschrieben.
Wisst ihr eigentlich,
wie man Bürgermeister richtig gendert?
Es ist, wenn man genau nimmt,
ist es der
Bürger,
also manche, die Noobs,
würden jetzt schreiben, BürgermeisterInnen,
aber
in Wirklichkeit
in Wirklichkeit ist es ja
BürgerInnen,
MeisterInnen, weil
Bürger
muss ja nicht ein Kerl sein.
Eigentlich wäre Bürgermeister
korrekt gegendert BürgerInnen, MeisterInnen.
Ja.
Und da wird es mir auch ein bisschen zu abgedreht,
ehrlich gesagt.
So, weiter. Oh, nur noch eine Minute. Fuck.
Ähm.
GPG for Win,
ArchieCrip, Veracrypt und Trooper sind
Programme zur Verschlüsselung
und Laufwerken.
Excellent. Und? Und?
100 Prozent. Leute, er hat
zwei Faktor-Authentifizierung mit der Zahl
2 gecheckt.
Easy.
So, letzte Prüfung.
Starten.
Auf geht's.
Hilmas ist
wieder am Start.
Findet bei Twitter einen Account von ihm,
den er nicht registriert hat.
Das waren die Hater bestimmt.
Mein Opa.
Mein Opa ist auf Twitch. Nice.
Easy.
Danke für den Prime-Sub.
Den er nicht registriert hat.
Offenbar hat jemand seine Identität
gestohlen. Was sollte Herr Hilmas
machen?
Ehrlich gesagt,
ignorieren?
Wahrscheinlich
ist es
ähm.
Ich mein, geht mal auf Twitter.
Und such da mal
nach MaxFPS.
Da findest du durchaus einige.
Und
who cares, ja.
Okay. Den Betrüger bei Twitter
per Direktnachricht anschreiben und ihn bitten,
den Account zu löschen.
Kann man probieren.
Wird wahrscheinlich
nichts bringen, weil das Konto inaktiv ist.
Anzeige bei der Polizei
erstatten. Nein, das Fake-Konto
bei Twitter melden. Ja.
Ja.
Neben seiner Stelle würde ich einfach einen neuen Account
erstellen.
HerrHilmas underscore 2022
oder sowas.
Frau Demir ist Systemadministratorin.
Ihr Chef meint,
Antivirensoftware anzuschaffen,
das wäre zu teuer und unnötig.
Ist es auch. Ist es.
Was wären gute Argumente
um ihren Chef vom G... Gar nicht.
Alles bloatet.
Der Chef hat recht.
Okay. Gute Antivirensoftware
findet Schadsoftware und kann sie unschädlich
machen. Ja, aber der Windows Defender
macht das auch schon.
Worüber man sich
unter genau
TheRealHilmas macht, dass ich einen Twitter-Account
ähm
also
worüber man sich vielleicht unterhalten kann, ist
für den File-Server sowas anzuschaffen oder sowas.
Also gehen wir mal davon aus, wie sie wollen
das wirklich, die wollen das wirklich an. Okay.
Äh, ja.
Vielleicht, vielleicht, vielleicht
haben sie auch einen Krypto-Miner mit dabei, wie
Norden-Antivirus neuerdings. Und
äh, ähm, ähm,
Avira auch.
Gute Antivirensoftware kann
Phishing-Vorfälle verhindern.
Kommt, kommt auf den
Phishing-Versuch an.
Äh,
möglich, ja.
Gute Antivirensoftware spart Kosten, die nach
einem für Hacker erfolgreichen Angriff
mit Schadsoftware entstehen.
Kann auch sein.
Gute Antivirensoftware schützt
das gesamte Firmennetzwerk.
Nein, das ist Schwachsinn.
Gute Antivirensoftware
installiert Sicherheitsabsätze für alle installierten
Projekte. Nein, das ist auch Schwachsinn.
Gute Antivirensoftware installiert
Sicherheitsabsätze für den Router und Schütze. Nein,
das ist auch Schwachsinn. Also ich würde es jetzt einfach
mal so lassen. So, weiter.
Frau Meier ist schon wieder am Start.
Also, der Herr Demir und die Frau Meier,
die haben echt was zu tun. Ist Frau Meier nicht auch
die, die montags bis freitags und samstags und sonntags
arbeiten und deswegen nicht in den Supermarkt gehen kann?
Jetzt ergibt das auch alles Sinn.
Ähm, also sie fragt ihren Kollegen
Herr Demir, ob sie auf einen Link
klicken sollte, den sie per E-Mail
vermeintlich von der Deutschen Bank zugesendet
bekommen hat.
Ja, wahrscheinlich
deutsches
deutsches echt, deutsche Bank
echt
at indiamail.cc
oder sowas.
Den sie per E-Mail vermeintlich von der Deutschen Bank
angeblich müsse das Geschäftskonkunft
aufgrund einer Unregelmäßigkeit überprüfen.
Der Absender ist Kundenbetrug
Deutsche Bank
Kontoprüfung 655
db.com
klingt äußerst vertrauenserweckend.
Was soll denn
dem Iran? Klicke unbesetzt, klicke
nicht auf den Link. So.
The real deutsche Bank
.ru
Die folgenden Wörter ein. Ein
bezeichnet einen Teil einer Software, der es
Hackern ermöglicht, Sicherheitseinschränkungen zu umgehen
und Zugriff zu Systemen zu bekommen.
Ein Exploit?
Oder?
Oder ein, ein, ein
Was wollen die denn da wissen?
Ne, ein
äh
Keylogger?
Ujana?
Back...
Ein Teil einer Software?
Der Gerät?
Also ich hätte, ich hätte
aus dem Bauch raus gesagt, Exploit.
Wobei ja Exploit eigentlich nicht
ganz korrekt ist.
Exploit ist ja quasi das Ausnutzen
einer sich... Ich hab kein
keine Ahnung, was die von mir wissen wollen.
Ein Exploit ist tatsächlich
nicht Teil einer Software. Das ist
richtig. Eigentlich ist der Exploit das Ausnutzen
einer sicher... Kann man da Sicherheitslücke
reinschreiben? Ne.
Ich hab wirklich keine Ahnung.
Ein Backdoor?
Bezeichnet einen Teil... Aber das ist doch kein Teil einer...
Ich hab...
Nein. Ich bleib
jetzt bei Exploit. Egal.
Ähm.
Mo, schon wieder, veröffentlicht
seinen kompletten Lebenslauf
mitsamt Bewerbungsfotos,
E-Mails, Adresse, Arbeiten auf allen
Social Media, Facebook, LinkedIn, Xing
und so weiter. Er hofft so auf
Jobangebote. Warum ist das keine
gute Idee?
Er könnte Opa von Doc singen.
Wer hat diese Texte geschrieben?
Die haben das wirklich nach Indien in Fiverr
über Fiverr nach Indien
outgesourced.
Er könnte Opa von
Doc singen werden. Naja.
Ne. Könnte er nicht. Er hat sich ja selber gedocst.
Er hat ja alles
hochgeladen. Er muss gar nicht mehr gedocst werden.
Er könnte mehr
Spam per E-Mail bekommen. Mit Sicherheit.
Er könnte Opfer von Social Media
Management werden?
Er könnte Opfer von Social
Media Management werden?
Von was?
Hä?
Das so... Ja, das könnte wahrscheinlich auch
... Wobei... Kein... Wahrscheinlich...
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Wir wollen bestimmt A und B hören.
Ich hab ehrlich
gesagt legit keinen blassen Schirm,
was da die richtige Antwort ist.
Weiter.
Sollte AdministratorInnen
Software in Unternehmen so konfigurieren...
Das ist an der Stelle auch noch falsch.
Sollten
AdministratorInnen
Software in Unternehmen
oder
AdministratorInnen
in dem Fall
Software in Unternehmen so konfigurieren, dass
diese sich automatisch aktualisieren?
Ja.
Nein. Sicherheitsprobe-Tests werden je nach
Software nur alle paar Wochen oder paar Monate
die Mitarbeiter...
Jawohl.
...trage den fehlenden
Fachbegriff ein.
Herr Meier ist CEO eines großen Konzerns
und findet plötzlich zahlreiche Accounts von sich
auf Xing, die er nicht angehängt hat.
In den Profilen gibt es viele Fotos
und private Daten von ihm. Offensichtlich ist er
Opfer von
Identitätsdiebstahl.
Wie schreibt man das?
Identitätsdiebstahl geworden.
Oh.
Was sind Anzeichen von Phishingversuchen
in E-Mails?
Fragen nach Zugangsdaten? Ja.
Fehlende Bilder oder Logos? Ja.
Kommt drauf an, aber ja.
Die tun sich oftmals schwer.
Die E-Mails...
Ja.
Test. E-Mail, das Absenden
passt nicht zum angezeigten Absendennamen.
Ja. Ja. Alles.
Okay.
Oh. 50%.
Oh Gott.
Das haben wir verschätzt, ne?
Okay. Frage 1.
Ich war mal falsch.
Anzeige. Anzeige.
Ich soll allen Ernstes
Anzeige erstatten, weil irgendjemand
Jilmaz01 mit meinem
Foto angelegt hat, oder was?
Anzeige.
Wegen dem Twitterprofil, was
jemand anderes angelegt hat.
Ich hab auch sonst nichts besseres zu tun.
Alter.
Alarm.
Okay. 2.
Gute Anti-Viren-Software schützt
das gesamte Firmennetz.
Nein.
Das ist Schwachsinn.
Zeig mir mal
eine gute Anti-Viren-Software, die das gesamte
Firmennetzwerk umfasst.
Was ist das denn?
Dumm.
Hier.
Hier kriegen wir keine Antwort drauf.
Keine Ahnung, was sie hier wissen wollen von einem.
Frage 8 ist falsch.
Wie fehlende Bilder und Logos nicht.
Aber fehlende Bilder und Logos kann da auch drauf
hindeuten.
Wenn du eine HTML-E-Mail kriegst
und da ist anstatt das deutsche Bank-Logo
auf einmal irgendwie ein China-Chinesen-Ding
drin, dann kannst du dir denken, da stimmt was nicht.
Rootkit.
Das.
Wobei, nein.
Das ergibt auch keinen Sinn.
Doch, das ergibt noch mehr Sinn.
Das ergibt noch mehr Sinn.
Bug.
Aber ein Bug
ermöglicht es Hackern nicht
automatisch Sicherheitseinstellungen zu umgehen.
Was auch immer.
Wir haben es geschafft, Leute.
Wir haben es geschafft.
Ich will mich nicht mehr verbessern.
Wo ist mein Zertifikat?
Was?
0 von 6?
Ich habe alles durch.
Ach so.
Ja gut, meine
E-Mail
Die E-Mail
ist ja auch
Was?
Moment, Level 1?
Hä?
Okay,
die Seite ist auch noch broken as fuck.
So,
wir machen jetzt noch mal
Wir machen jetzt mal eine Sache.
Mich interessiert mal aus was diese Webseite besteht.
Okay, schau mal nicht
Wobei, das ist html.
Wobei, Sourcecode?
Kein minified Sourcecode und nix.
Was ist denn hier los?
Auf was basiert denn das Ganze?
Wir machen einfach awesome stack
Awesome tech stack
Wir lassen einfach mal die Seite analysieren
und uns sagen, was die
was die verwenden.
Jawoll, das da.
Analysiere
Analysiere die Seite mal
und sag mir, was die verwenden.
jQuery?
Wait a minute.
Das stimmt wahrscheinlich noch nicht.
Mal kurz warten, bis das
bis das fertig analysiert hat.
Es ist erst Beta.
Stimmt.
Underscore Lodash. Okay, erstmal beides drinne.
Backbone.js?
Alter, das ist ja antik
das Ding.
jQuery UI?
jQuery Minecraft, jQuery Anime CS
MySQL
Wordpress
Okay, Captcha.
Wordpress, jQuery
Warum verwendet es
Backbone
und PHP?
Backbone ist ja eigentlich
Ne, Moment, sorry. Backbone war so
eines der ersten Client-Side-Frameworks.
Was ist denn das?
Das ist ja antik as fuck.
Wer verwendet denn sowas?
So sah der Tech-
So sah der Tech-Stack mal vor
vor 10 Jahren aus.
Awesomeness
Quality Report
Die Webseite hat wahrscheinlich
10 Jahre Entwicklung gebraucht.
Ja, das wird's wahrscheinlich sein.
Boah, das ist aber schlecht.
Nicht mal jQuery
Nee, das ist
das ist schlecht, ja.
Wenigstens jQuery erwartet.
Okay.
Performance ist schlecht.
Best Practice ist es aber.
Performance, 41%.
Sucked.
Okay.
Na denn?
Wissen wir Bescheid, jetzt haben wir den Internet-Führerschein.
Code this, not that.
Okay, wenn wir gerade dabei sind.
Ach, in React. Nee, in React
nicht. Von React habe ich keinen Plan.
Von React habe ich keinen Plan.
Interview with a Perl Programmer.
Okay, das gucken wir jetzt mal.
Perl. Perl-Hackermans.
Boah, mein Zahnarzt schon wieder.
Okay, Moment, wo sind wir?
Perl-Programmer.
Okay, das ist nicht lustig.
Critical Update inbound.
Da kommt doch eh nix
Gescheites.
Leute, ich könnte morgen ein Video über den Internet-Führerschein machen,
nachdem wir das jetzt ja durch haben.
Wo ich ja sag, das ist sehr fragwürdig, was da teilweise
drinnen gefragt wird.
A big Battlefield 2042 update may be coming this week.
Big Update. Big Update heißt,
zwei neue Skins und drei Sachen wurden
gefixt.
By the way, Sekunde, Sekunde,
Sekunde.
Steam, Steam Stats.
Unter 2000 sind wir jetzt schon.
Not stonks.
Es geht abwärts.
Obwohl man eigentlich gar nicht
für Möglichkeiten hat, es geht weiter abwärts.
Und New World,
New World, was macht New World?
Kackt auch weiter ab.
Excellent.
Die Abkacker sind weiter am abkacken, wunderbar.
Geht ab wie der russische Rubel, ja.
In die gleiche Richtung.
Die nächste Update von Battlefield 2042
wird wahrscheinlich live dieses Wochenende sein.
Es wird eine neue Scoreboard als
Headline-Feature geben.
Ein Blogpost mit Passnoten wird am
Dienstag live sein, mit all den Infos.
Die Pension, die Update selbst,
wird am Dienstag live sein.
Natürlich wäre es eine Länge, die neue Scoreboard
Content zu nennen, aber das ist die erste Update,
die wirklich eine große Feature
in das Spiel bringt. Alle vorherigen Updates
haben sich entweder auf Bugfixing oder
Balance-Adjustierung konzentriert.
Von dieser Update weiter erwarten wir mehr
Veränderungen zum Spiel, wie Voice-Chat,
neue Maps, neue Waffen und mehr.
Die Antwort auf diese Update, die potenziell live
läuft, ist ein bisschen vermischt, aber
es scheint, dass alles, was das Spiel
näher an die Erwartungen der Fans
bringt, willkommen ist.
Also ganz ehrlich, das Spiel ist dadurch nicht
weiter großartig nennenswert an meine
Erwartungen herangerückt.
DICE hat vorhin gesagt, dass diese Update
das Produkt der Arbeit über den
Weihnachtsabbruch war. Viele der Bugs und
Probleme, die seitdem berichtet wurden,
sollten beantwortet werden. Legacy-Feature.
Das Spiel wurde von den
DICE-Developern aufgelöst und
das erste Spiel von Ark Raiders
2020 eröffnet.
Das hat mich ehrlich gesagt nicht so sehr
geschockt. Das sind ehemalige DICE-Mitarbeiter.
Das hat mich nicht so geschockt.
Ich spiele als 3-Person-Koop-Schütze,
die dich in eine Welt schießt, die über
massive Maschinen dominiert. Heute haben sie
die Registrierung für den Spieltest eröffnet.
Wenn du 18 oder älter bist, kannst du
dein Name und E-Mail auf ihrer Website
signen. Sie bieten digital und im Personschiff
Tests. Es ist unklar, ob die Konsol-Playtests
in der Registrierung ein Bild von jemandem
mit einem Maus und Keyboard zeigen, aber
das Spiel wird auf PC, Playstation...
Wo spielt denn der Typ, wenn man
so eine Jacke anhaben muss beim Spielen?
Ist da Minus?
... somebody using a mouse and keyboard,
but the game is launching on PC,
Playstation 5 and Xbox.
So chances are, playtesting will be
multiplatform. Maybe the bigger question
is, well, what will the game actually be
like and if its monetization model
will be favorable. Ark Raiders
Reveal-Trailer was a flashy spectacle
showcasing the game's massive scale
in combat, but it's tough to say how close
to actual gameplay the trailer is.
The game is also being published by Nexon,
who have a history of kind of
over-monetizing their free-to-play games.
That said, they're also the
publisher for Final Fantasy 14,
which is one of the most well-regarded
MMOs around right now. Ultimately,
Ark Raiders looks like an epic mashup of
Monster Hunter and third-person
Battlefield. The playtest will probably
coincide with actual gameplay footage in
either a trailer or clips from
participants. Hopefully it lives up to the hype.
Reviews of Valve's portable gaming
console, the Steam Deck, flooded
YouTube and gaming news sites over the past
few days. The nearly universal
consensus is that it's a
best-in-class device for many reasons.
The first is its pricing.
The cheapest Steam Deck option is
less than $500, which is half
or even less than $500.
The first is its pricing.
The cheapest Steam Deck option is
less than $500, which is
half or even less than most competing
portable PCs.
On top of the low price, the
Steam Deck's hardware is cutting-edge
and performs well enough to run
most gaming devices.
Both Steam Deck and Steam Deck
have a launchpad that
allows you to play
multiplayer games with
a fan of the Steam Deck as
well as other PC models.
The best part is that each
Steam Deck device has an
cutting edge and performs well enough to run most games at 60 FPS on low settings.
Considering the Screen size and 720P resolution, you're not really giving anything up by reducing
settings.
Even the software experience is notably improved over competing products.
SteamOS, being based on Linux, is certainly a bottleneck for AAA multiplayer titles like
Apex Legends, Rainbow Six Siege, Battlefield, and Call of Duty, but the list of compatible
Games is growing every day and nothing stops you from running a Windows install on the
Steam Deck if you really want to.
The biggest negative most reviewers pointed out was the buggy software.
This is a first gen product for Valve.
That means stuff like the navigation can be a bit wonky at times.
The Steam Store doesn't have an easy way of tracking down every Steam Deck compatible
title and the highlight features like Clouds Spend and Resume only work in specific circumstances.
All that said, it seems like the Steam Deck has a bright future.
The real selling point for many gamers and developers is that the Steam Deck is the first
PC gaming device built for portable gaming that's both accessible and convenient.
Robust components, Valve have genuinely come to demand.
It's entirely possible that developers will start making games with Steam Deck support.
This is the power of Steam Deck.
They have joined the force to make the Steam Deck.
They seem to not have the let's play experience and they are more of the
Bitboxer type players.
Also, they're also the only one who's got the skill literacy experience.
So, was gucken wir uns denn jetzt an?
Mein Zahnarzt ist wieder am Start.
Leute, der Chat sagt das Video wäre nicht gut.
Incredible Budget Server.
Wo is er denn?
Minecraft, installing Linux.
Wie das sieht aus wie ein Kühlschrank.
Leute, das sieht aus wie ein Kühlschrank gerade, auch mit der Spiegeltür.
Schau das Wasser versus Drau.
Herz geschnallt.
stocker das ist 40 minuten lang oder so das gucke ich mir jetzt nicht an in 20
minuten das gucken wir uns jetzt nicht an battle field has the new contender
was seine kleidung über dich verrät
legostells okay wir schauen mal was uns was uns youtube noch empfiehlt ich wie
gesagt gleiches bett getimed gleiches bett getimed ja kein wunder dass das jetzt
trendet ein bisschen wo ich jetzt mal ein bisschen gedanken macht's mir macht
es mir schon für mich ist diese ganze geschichte mit atomkrieg und sonst was
das ist so irgendwas in grauer vorzeit zu 1980 oder so so nach dem motto das
haben wir schon lange hinter uns gelassen
wie macht mich macht insofern ein bisschen gedanken dass jetzt öffentlich
sogar schon im fernsehen von der politik quasi solche wörter um sie in mut
genommen werden also spricht da ist schon ein bisschen die kacke am dampfen
das war ja schon ein bisschen gedanken wenn ich ehrlich bin
ich bin ein bisschen gedanken wenn ich ehrlich bin
ich bin ein bisschen gedanken wenn ich ehrlich bin natürlich sollten wir alle
hoffen dass nichts auch nur ansatzweise in dieser richtung passiert weil sonst
sind wir einfach alle der morgen nicht bett gehen sondern der truth about web
designers das ist ein risitas video moment dass das muss einfach mal gucken
ob das was taugt
manchmal kozin umbeizuschalten
okay okay
kom independent e Return
und
imcak
ta Wolfgang
für die
oping
M重要
Das war's für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Okay, Sekunde.
Was ist denn CSS?
Das ist das, das dafür sorgt, dass zum Beispiel
der Hintergrund dieses Buttons rot ist.
Styling für Webseiten ist das.
Wow.
Alter, wenn du da die Hand dazwischen hast, ist aber
nicht gut. Das schlägt
dir die Hand komplett durch.
Alter, wenn du da die Hand dazwischen hast,
ist aber vorbei.
I wanna point out that this disc
is regulation. It does have this minor
issue of so much kick that it'll break
your arm. Ja.
And a 100-mile-per-hour frisbee going past
your face. So naturally we have
to see how bad it would be if you got hit.
This ended up being my
most labor-intensive project
ever. Everything that could break
broke. I mean, heck, it broke twice.
Alter, ich würde mich nicht trauen, das selbst auszulösen
bei mir am Arm.
I even had to make my own valves.
Like a lot of my projects, the journey
is the destination. So, buckle up.
Disc golf is just like normal
golf, played with discs. You play
a series of holes where you try to get the discs
into a basket with the minimum number of throws.
Das gibt es als
competitive? Frisbee-Scheibe
werfen, gibt es als competitive Sport?
Serious? Wusste ich nicht.
Okay, es gibt alles irgendwie als competitive
Sport. You typically start with a long-distance
drive, get close to the basket, and then you
putt it in. I enjoy
making things go really, really fast. So, I'm gonna
focus on the drive, and my goal
is to make the disc go as fast as
humanly possible. Echt, das gibt's
bei Olympia? Jetzt jebatet mich
der Chandler, oder? Es gibt
Frisbee-Golf? Nein, das kann ich mir
nicht vorstellen.
Jebatet.
Richtig, richtig
huge jebatet.
You got jebatet.
Got jebatet.
And according to the internet,
the fastest disc ever thrown
was 89 and a half
miles per hour by Simon Lizotti.
So, our target is 90 miles per hour.
I've been wanting to...
Könnt ihr mal gescheite Einheiten verwenden?
Was ist 90 Meilen
pro Stunde?
Ist das 120
Kilometer pro Stunde, oder was
ist das? 90
to kmh.
144.
Alter,
also, das nervt
mich an den Amis, ja.
Freedom units.
Wenn man Mäuse bei Amazon.com
sucht, kriegt man ein Gewicht in
ounces. Das, das nervt
mich wirklich. Könnt ihr mal was Gescheites
verwenden?
To make something like this for quite a while.
And I have a vision of how I think
it would work. Imagine a thing that you could hold
that gave your arm an extra joint.
And it was powered and could spin
super fast on command.
And then it had the ability to hold a Frisbee on the end.
As you swung this thing, it would fire
and give you a ton of extra speed.
Ja gut,
das gibt's ja so Werfdinger für so
Bälle für, also, kennt ihr diese Werfarme
für so Bälle, wo man mit
seinem Hund spielen kann?
Da gibt es auch so, so Wurfarme.
Und damit kann halt auch wirklich
der letzte Kacknub das Ding übelst weit
und volle Pulle schmeißen.
Das ist halt einfach nur ein Plastikteil.
Das größte Problem mit diesem Design ist die Reaktion-Force.
Es wird wie ein Pferd schießen.
Wenn es das Frisbee ausführt,
gibt es eine gleiche und opposite Kraft,
die in dein Arm schießt.
Das könnte dein Schuss oder sogar dich verletzen.
Thanks a lot, Isaac Newton.
But wait, if I launch two Frisbees
in opposite directions,
they'll push on each other and it'll cancel out.
So we just need an extra arm on our launcher
and we'll use a weight instead of a Frisbee.
I need some kind of power source that I can use.
Einfach die Frisbee schneller als Lichtgeschwindigkeit
schmeißen, dann kommt sie an, bevor du sie abschießt.
Easy.
To accelerate this arm and launch the Frisbee.
In the past I've used explosive blanks
to launch stuff really fast, but I don't think
they're suitable in this case.
And that's because they're just too fast.
Oh yeah, it's kaputt.
If we attach the chain to the sprocket,
it will unwind as it launches the arm,
and then it will wind the other way,
which pulls the piston back out, acting like a brake.
I really like this design.
There's no extra parts for me to make,
break, and then remake.
High IQ strats.
Holding and releasing the disc is really hard.
Humans are crazy, and we're not going to be making a hand.
So I'm going to have the disc sit on a flat plane,
held down by fingers around the rim.
The fingers will have a trigger mechanism
that will let me drop them all in sync.
That's the basic design.
Two counter-rotating arms,
one holding a Frisbee,
with little claws,
powered by a high-pressure air system.
So, und jetzt erst mal 3D-Drucker anwerfen.
Alright, let's get this thing made.
Wobei, 3D-Drucker sind nicht stabil genug dafür.
Oh, crap.
This hole's supposed to be over here.
This part is too big to fail.
If anyone asks, you didn't see anything.
Everything is super beefy,
because the forces and torques are ridiculous.
This thing has a lot of round parts,
which means a lot of lathe work.
You know what?
Don't even ask.
Getting square-edged holes is something...
Ich finde das fast schon hypnotisierend,
diese Drehbank-Videos auf YouTube.
Die gucke ich teilweise echt gerne zum Einschlafen abends.
Da gibt's Videos, dann bauen dann Leute,
was weiß ich, Vasen, irgendwelche Ständer und sonst was.
Da spannen die in ein großes Stück Holz ein
und drechseln dann so vor sich hin.
Das Video geht dann irgendwie zweieinhalb Stunden oder so
und da kann man richtig gut bei pennen.
Sometimes a real problem.
Das ist das Armbracelet und wird in der Form meines Armes geformt.
Hey, Frau.
Ja?
Könntest du sehen, ob wir ein Rad haben,
das im gleichen Größe wie mein Bicep ist?
Ja, sicher.
Sehr cool.
Wenn du verstehen willst, was die Teile von diesen Werkzeugen sind,
schau dir mein Shop-Tour an.
Ich habe so viele Teile 3D-geprintet, wie ich konnte,
aber die Kräfte sind so hoch,
dass fast alles Metall war.
Sobald die Teile fertig sind...
Nein, das ist halt auch richtig schwer, das Teil dann.
Alter, das Video geht 28 Minuten.
What the fuck?
Ich dachte, das gehen 14 Minuten oder so.
Ich muss bald back in, back in time.
Aber es interessiert mich jetzt, was da rauskommt.
Die letzten paar Minuten sind immer so wichtig.
Gut, dann gucken wir mal, bis das Ding funktioniert.
Warum nicht?
Pressluftflasche im Schritt.
Mein Instinkt ist es, das zu meinem Arm zu befestigen und es einen Schuss zu geben.
Aber das ist eine wirklich schlechte Idee.
Ich fahre diesen Luftzylinder mit 6-mal seiner Wertung.
Ich habe seine Schwierigkeiten analysiert.
Oh, China. Chinesische Herstellung.
Aber meine größte Angst ist eigentlich das Ding, das rundherum fliegt.
Wenn etwas teilweise entdeckt wurde,
könnte es rumfliegen und mir den Arsch wegwerfen.
Wir werden das wirklich genau testen, bevor ich es zu meinem Körper befestige.
Wann immer du so etwas für das erste Mal testest,
ist es immer wirklich nervig.
Es kann alles passieren.
Ich bin also am sichersten Ort in meinem Shop.
Los geht's.
Drei, zwei, eins.
Das war etwa 30-mal schneller, als es sein sollte.
Das ist lustig, aber auch wirklich furchtbar.
Obwohl ich glaube, ich weiß vielleicht, wer der Verletzter ist.
Ich bin wirklich nicht sicher, was in dieser Flasche passiert.
Es fühlt sich alles gut an und die Friktion ist niedrig.
Aber wenn man viel Druck durch diese Flaschen macht,
versuchen sie, sich zusammen zu drücken.
Ich denke, das schiebt sie in die Seite der Flasche
und generiert eine Menge Friktion.
Wir werden also die Flasche modifizieren,
um die Flaschen zwischen den Flaschen und der Wand zu befestigen.
Hoffentlich funktioniert es dieses Mal.
Drei, zwei, eins.
Oh, warum?
Ich habe also viele Tests gemacht.
Ich denke, dass diese Flasche Teil der Verschiebung ist.
Ich versuche, meine Discluncher von innen zu unterbinden.
Die Grund, warum ich diese Flasche benutze,
ist, dass jemand auf Amazon sagte, dass es für ihren Kartoffelkanon funktioniert hat.
Ich dachte, das klingt toll.
Ich habe also einen Kartoffelkanon.
Ja, coole Geschichte, Herr Kartoffelkopf,
wenn das sogar dein echter Name ist.
Ich habe gerade die Mathematik gemacht,
die ich vorhin schon gemacht hätte,
über den Luftfluss, den ich durch diese Flasche machen kann.
Und es gibt keine Chance, dass es funktioniert.
Diese Flasche ist zwischen dem Tank von hohem Druck und der pneumatischen Zylinder.
Und das Problem ist, dass es einen kleinen kleinen Loch hat,
der nur ein wenig Luft durchlässt,
sodass die Pistole sehr langsam bewegt.
Leider kann ich nicht schnell eine passende Flasche bekommen.
Und ich will sie jetzt.
Also werden wir unsere eigene Flasche machen.
Wir fangen mit einem riesigen Loch an,
mit dem das ganze Luftfluss durchlaufen kann.
Dann geben wir einen Pistolen, der die Flasche öffnen und öffnen kann.
Der Druck von der Flasche wird die Flasche nach unten drücken und die Flasche öffnen.
Wir können auch unseren hohen Druckluftfluss nutzen, um das zu machen.
Wir brauchen nur eine kleine Flasche, um die Flasche auf und ab zu schalten.
Das ist ein perfekter Nutzen für diese Flasche, die ich nicht nötig fand.
Und du weißt den Drill.
Wir müssen es jetzt machen.
Das ist die Flasche.
Ich meine, du musst erstmal den ganzen Kram daheim haben, ne?
Also, ich meine, ich habe hier schon viel Gedöns.
An Werkzeugen und 3D Drucker und alles mögliche.
Aber ich hätte bei weitem nicht genug sowas hier herzustellen.
Und das Problem ist, wenn du damit nur ab und zu mal was machst.
Der Kram ist ja auch gerade so Metallbearbeitungsdinger.
Die sind halt fucking teuer.
Der Typ hat einfach alles, ja.
Der hat wahrscheinlich einmal Amazon per Skript leer bestellt oder so.
It goes in like a glove.
It really is pretty simple.
I did integrate a safety stick, which prevents the valve from opening until I'm definitely ready.
Let me show you the difference between these valves.
Here's the old one.
Three, two, one.
Now I'm gonna show you what a real valve does.
Two, one.
Jetzt macht er pfiit und ist voll.
Boah!
It's just too much stress for the balloon handle.
Es muss klatschen. Bam, bam, bam.
The balloon is gone in five thousandths of a second.
Balloons are cool, but it would be really cool if it actually works.
Three, two, one.
Man, so slow.
This is starting to get pretty annoying, actually.
Come on.
Alright, I think I found another problem.
I'm very hesitant to say the problem, because I've said that three times already.
Basically, we have a bottleneck in our bottleneck.
Let me show you.
Oh, come on.
Hold on.
I don't have the right tool.
Okay, let me show you.
And this is the regulator.
The tank actually has a super duper high pressure inside of it,
and the regulator allows it to output a constant lower pressure,
even as that pressure inside the tank changes.
Here's what's inside.
It's a lot of interesting stuff.
But the main takeaway is there's another tiny hole.
Tiny holes are bad.
Alright, it's starting to get a little bit complicated,
but we're gonna add a second tank that has no regulator.
The main tank pressurizes the secondary tank before we fire.
The second tank has a big hole, which can deliver all the air when we fire.
Alright, let's try again.
Ignore the fact that it didn't release.
That's a software bug.
The speed is way better, but what is with this kick?
Oh my goodness.
I know what is happening.
I think of stupid and smart as a continuum.
You have stupid over here, smart over here, and everything in between.
But what you might not realize is it's actually a circle.
And it's possible to do something that you think is really smart.
You actually rapped all the way back around to stupid,
which is exactly what I did right here with this torque problem.
Also, er möchte uns damit sagen, er war so two-head,
dass er schon six-head geworden ist wieder.
Oder er war so six-head, dass er schon wieder three-head geworden ist,
oder so was.
In der Richtung, möchte er uns sagen.
But from this view, the top arm is pushing this way,
and the bottom arm is pushing that way,
which wants to twist the launcher like a lot.
So, I calculated how much torque this would put on your arm,
and it's about the torque output of a Honda Civic.
So, I'm gonna remove this lower arm.
This will cut the torque in half.
Although it does mean we're gonna get the kick that I was trying to cancel out.
So, to try to make that better,
I'm gonna make all the mass moving up here as light as possible.
Wäre es nicht sinnvoller, irgendwas zu machen, was dreht?
Was, was, was diese Frisbee-Scheibe irgendwie kann?
Keine Ahnung.
Auf 5.000 Umdrehungen oder was auch immer beschleunigt, rauskickt,
oder keine Ahnung.
So ein Arm?
The downside is I have to redesign and remake everything that moves.
Yeah, that's not great.
CNC is the best. I call it the finger flinger.
Der hat aber wirklich alles da.
So eine CNC-Maschine, das kostet ja auch schon.
Was kostet denn so was?
Eine Scheibe. 20.000 Euro?
Keine Ahnung, das muss mega teuer sein.
And then it can just swing away freely.
Die Sachen kosten insgesamt bestimmt deutlich mehr.
Three, two, one.
Oh, das klatscht schon ein bisschen mehr.
Hopefully that was a fluke.
It can throw alright sometimes,
but if there's any wobble, it just pops out.
Slight redesign.
Hopefully this holder will keep it stable.
Alright, let's try it.
Boah!
Jetzt erst mal komplett zerfetzt, das Ding.
I think I somehow managed to make it worse.
This is the super-duper holder, which super-duper supports the disc.
Three, two, one.
Oh!
Oh, I got it wrong. It's the super-duper waste of time.
Wieso? Es sah doch jetzt ganz gut aus erst mal.
I just don't see any way of making the disc stand here without making this too heavy.
Hast du schon mitbekommen, dass Algorithmen Verstehen sich renamed hat? Ja.
Original holder and try to make it really light.
Ja, ja, habe ich schon mitbekommen.
Any maps that can't tell me what it would say it does here is gone.
Da heißt es jetzt wie sein echter Name.
Everything is skeletonized. Lighter fasteners.
And I modified it to use the finger trigger because it's a lot lighter.
So, before I sink any more time into this, I want to actually test it with me holding it.
I'm gonna do it at an extremely low power.
This will let me test the whole system.
It will also let me test the throwing modes.
So, up until now I've been using bench mode,
which, if I hold this button for two seconds, it'll trigger it.
But it also has throwing mode.
There's an accelerometer and gyroscope on that.
Ah!
Das ist genau den gleichen Analog-Digital-Konverter habe ich auch.
Wobei, nee, ist das überhaupt einer?
Nee, das ist so ein Motor...
Nee, was ist denn das?
Das ist kein Motortreiber-Ding.
Ach, ein Gyroscope ist das. Stimmt.
Dass da weiß, wie das hält.
Wie das Ding gehalten wird.
Ja, das ist sinnvoll.
...that monitors the tilt and rotation of it.
When it reaches a certain point in the throwing motion,
it will trigger it to fire the frisbee.
Time to just go for it.
Also, ganz ehrlich, der Helm ist ja schön und gut,
aber ich hätte eher Gedanken um meinen Arm.
Was soll ich hier machen?
Ein bisschen Rückstoß, ne?
Three, two, one.
It seems like the disc isn't releasing at the right point.
Oh!
Hey!
I think that assessment might have some merit.
Something somewhere is broken and I don't know what it is.
So I'm gonna stop before I hurt myself
and try to figure out what the heck is going on.
Na, das funktioniert nicht so ganz.
What the fuck, was geht denn jetzt im Chat auf einmal ab?
1KS?
Wurde ich gehostet und habe irgendwas übersehen, oder?
Zack?
Captain Sammy, danke für den Sub!
Hab ich überhaupt nicht mitgekriegt? Normalerweise sollte es eigentlich...
eine Einblendung geben, aber okay.
Tja, was auch immer.
Huge raid! Massive!
Dankeschön für den raid.
Ich bin aber auch in 5 Minuten ungefähr off.
Wir gucken uns nur noch dieses Video hier an und dann ist Schluss.
Bad kid time!
Ich will jetzt nur noch sehen, ob der Kram funktioniert oder nicht.
Weil aktuell sieht es ja eher danach aus, als reißt er sich gleich den Arm ab oder sowas.
You solve one problem, you create another. The discs are jamming.
Now that we're going really fast, I think the extreme acceleration forces are jamming the triggers so they don't open.
Which means that we get to redesign and remake the triggers.
Wir hosten NASA. Ja, wir hosten halt die NASA.
Okay, this should be practically unjammable.
Alright, 10% power, here we go.
Und?
Alright, that looks great. 25%.
Nice!
What?
Was ist Switch noch gemutet? Danke für dein Host.
Progress host.
Also, aktuell sieht das nicht so aus, als funktioniert dieser Kram, oder?
Leute, ich muss gleich off.
Ich überleg grad, ob ich ein bisschen vorspulen soll.
Danke fürs Informatik Interesse weg. Nice!
Two checker mans.
Nice!
I think this actually works.
75%. We're going for it.
Ins Fitnessstudio um 22 Uhr.
Ja, dann viel Spaß.
Two, one.
Boah, alter, das fetzt ja rein, das Ding mittlerweile.
Das fetzt so sehr rein, dass es so auseinanderfetzt.
The disc popped out immediately.
Direkt.
A lot of stuff just happened.
We broke the carbon fiber tube, which I don't think is that big of a mystery.
Siehste, ich hab doch am Anfang gesagt, der Kram ist viel zu schwer.
Jetzt hat er Carbon-Steels am Start.
Popping out early is just really, really bad.
Normally, most of the energy goes into the disc, and when it's released, it takes it away.
But when the disc pops out early, all that energy goes into the arm, which makes it go super fast.
24-7, okay.
Ja, ich weiß, wir haben ja auch welche, die 24-7 offen sind, aber ich bin ja schon normalerweise zu faul, ins Fitnessstudio zu gehen.
Ja, wenn ich auf meine eineinhalb, zwei Stunden am Tag normalerweise bin.
Dann bin ich ja schon froh.
Aber ich bin viel zu faul, jetzt noch aus dem Haus zu gehen und dann auch noch ins Fitnessstudio.
Ich könnte mich da nicht zu überwinden.
Mr. Hedgehog, danke für den Primestop.
Slam into the stop system with gusto.
You could say it turns the brake system into the brake system.
We're gonna replace the tube with titanium, which doesn't shatter.
Now the real mystery is why the disc is popping out almost immediately.
Boah, das hat aber richtig Zug drauf, mittlerweile.
Boah, das hat aber richtig Zug drauf, mittlerweile, das Ding, was er da gebaut hat.
Ich würde mir auch Gedanken machen, wenn ich in dem Raum rumstehe und an die Scheibe durch den Raum fliege.
I think this is aerodynamics this time, because it's happening almost immediately before it starts going fast.
I think this is actually g-forces.
The disc is going from zero to sixty in a few thousandths of a second.
This pushes the disc into the arm with over a hundred pounds of force.
I think it's pushing the disc so hard that it bends like this, which lets it pop out of the fingers.
The acceleration begins immediately, which is why the disc would fly out when it's not even going fast.
So my thought is, if there's no gap to squeeze through, then it can't squeeze through.
Let's put that shower thought to a test.
This fully supports the back edge of the frisbee, which I hope...
Wahrscheinlich bricht jetzt die Frisbee-Scheibe durch, wenn sie sich nicht mehr bewegen kann.
I'm using one of the trigger fingers to keep the disc in.
Then when we're ready to fire, we can open the trigger finger and the disc should roll out of this holder.
I'm so tired of making grippers, please work.
Three, two, one...
Bam.
Boah, das knallt ja mal richtig rein.
Yeah, that's definitely going to be a no for me, dog.
I'm really tempted to make a custom solid metal disc, which can't bend, but that would be deadly.
And also not regulation.
I think the answer is to pull on the disc from the front.
This will want to stretch the disc out rather than compressing it, and it shouldn't bend.
So that means we get to redesign and remake the disc holder for...
I don't even know.
Okay, ich roll mal ein bisschen vor, ich muss jetzt nämlich wirklich bald pennen.
Before I sink a ton of time...
Boah, also das Ding, das haut schon richtig rein mittlerweile.
I couldn't have hit more things if I tried, but as far as I'm concerned, that is the sound of victory.
I think.
We just have to make it for real and find out.
It's 95% carbon fiber because I need maximum strength and minimum weight.
Der Typ hat auch einen Laser-Cutter und alles, der hat alles daheim, oder?
It's basically the same way you make a drone.
Carbon fiber, titanium, aerospace-grade aluminum, all to throw a piece of plastic.
You'd think we're trying to go to the moon here.
This is just like the prototype, except there's a little trap door holding the disc in place.
If this doesn't work, I give up.
Three, two, one.
Boah, das, das, das muss klatschen.
Was ist dann aerospace-grade Aluminium so speziell?
Keine Ahnung.
Es ist Aluminium, wo irgendeiner gesagt hat,
das ist aerospace-grade.
Kein Stimme.
Das erinnert mich an diese Geschichte.
Ich hab mal vor Urzeiten, hab ich mal eine Netzwerkkarte gekauft in einem Laden.
Also zu Zeiten, wo Aeon 45 Stecker und BNC Stecker noch beide an Netzwerkkarten dran waren.
Und der Typ in dem Laden hat mir damals auch erzählt,
die Netzwerkkarte basiert auf irgendwie NASA-Technologie oder sowas.
Und ich war halt so dumm und hab dem das damals geglaubt.
Oder Technologie aus der Raumfahrt und bla bla bla.
Das war einfach ganz, einfach ganz billiger Bait, dass ich den Kram kaufe.
Finally it works.
This has been such a slog.
This is the most time I've put into any project.
And a lot happened.
So let me summarize.
We made the original design, which had bearing issues.
Ich will das jetzt mal in Aktion sehen.
If it can't, that would be really, really disappointing.
Remember, the speed to beat?
Eighty-nine and a half miles per hour.
Ich meine, ich finde es schon erstaunlich, dass es tatsächlich competitive Frisky-Werfen gibt.
Frisbee-Werfen.
But before we do that, I'm gonna throw the disc so that we get a human baseline.
I already know that I suck, so you don't have to tell me that.
Alright, it's the robot's turn.
Three, two, one.
Klatscht schon richtig.
Eighty-five miles per hour at forty percent power.
That is what I'm talking about.
Alright, let's step it up.
Wow, that's it.
Could we do a hundred miles per hour?
Da bricht jetzt bestimmt das Holz durch.
Max power.
In three, two, one.
Das war's.
Guckt euch an, wie das Plastik-Ding das Holz splittet.
It looks like the centrifugal force was so high that it pulled the gripper off the titanium rod.
I have the clamps maxed out, so to fix this would take some new parts.
Since we're already exceeding ninety miles per hour, let's just call seventy-five percent one hundred.
I grab some dimensions off this still frame before impact, and I calculate that the disc is going about a hundred and fifteen miles per hour.
But it is a weird perspective, so take that with a big grain of salt.
I think it's a really bad idea to hold this launcher.
The disc can come off, and when it does, it's deadly.
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Boring.
We've demonstrated that it's fine at lower power, so let's do it.
But we are not going over fifteen percent power.
Alright, here we go.
In three, two, one.
Da hätte ich echt beide Bedenken, das Ding in der Hand zu halten.
Ganz ehrlich? Das wäre mir ein wenig zu heikel.
Yeah, it's probably a good time to end it.
I forgot to aim. This thing is amazing. I love this.
It's fast, but how far can it go?
I really don't want to take it to a park.
This is the kind of thing that generates interest that you don't really want.
So thankfully we have a family friend with a really long field.
I bet it's going to go so far.
Three, two, one.
Boah!
Das ist ja fast wie so ein Ding, was die auf irgendwelchen Schießständen und sowas haben.
Da werfen die doch auch so Scheiben für die ganzen Shotgun-Dudes.
Directly into the manure.
Alright, let's try again.
Three, two, one.
Do a barrel roll!
My very shallow understanding is that discs flipping over is a fundamental behavior.
How much discs want to do this is so important. It's actually one of the ratings for the discs.
I'm using discs that don't want to flip over, but they're not designed for the speeds that I'm going and they're still wanting to flip.
I tested all the discs in all the configurations.
Some are alright.
Some are terrible.
I'm getting about 550 feet, which is less than half of the human distance record.
Which really highlights how insane that record is.
So you'd think if I'm throwing it faster than any human, it would go further than any human can throw.
But it's actually really complicated.
Discs are basically wings in gyroscopes.
How much the disc wants to flip and how efficiently it flies is extremely dependent on the design.
I think if I want to come anywhere near the distance record, I'm probably going to have to design my own disc.
For the speeds that I'm throwing at.
And I also think I'm going to need a lot more spin.
When the disc spins, it stabilizes itself from tipping just like a gyroscope.
And I think I'll also need a really strong tailwind.
You know what? Hold on.
Oh, that's really close.
But I'm not a woman.
So I brought the wife out to press the button, in which case I think it counts because she's a woman.
Who could argue with that?
Alright, here we go.
Three.
Three, two, one.
Okay, not the strongest start. Let's try again.
Woah.
That was a good one.
You can see how far it went.
160.
Wisst ihr, was das Geile ist?
Dass mittlerweile Drohnen, solche Dinger hier, nicht mehr so teuer sind.
Also im Vergleich zu früher, wo die für irgendwelche Naturaufnahmen noch mit einem Helikopter rumgeflogen sind,
heute kann sich jeder 0815-Hobby-Dude so eine Drohne kaufen, eine ordentliche Kamera dran machen und rumfliegen.
Was eigentlich ziemlich nice ist.
Ich habe schon ein paar YouTube-Videos gesehen.
Leute auf Island, die sind da mit ihrer Drohne rumgeflogen.
Bessere Aufnahmen als noch vor zehn Jahren überhaupt möglich gewesen sind mit großem Budget.
Also das ist eine richtig geile Geschichte.
Und angeblich ist Drone Racing eines der beliebtesten Hotels.
Eines der beliebtesten Hobbys mittlerweile.
Habe ich gelesen.
Ich kenne keinen Drone Racer.
Und weiter.
Skip.
Kommt da noch was?
Wie, das war es jetzt?
Wo? Wo?
Moment, ich wollte gerade sagen, wo ist die Melone?
Hier ist die Melone.
Ich glaube, es geht los.
Ich will die Melone sehen.
Die splittet.
Es ist Zeit, herauszufinden, was passieren würde, wenn du eine exzeptionell leichte Hände hättest
und davon getroffen wärst.
Drei, zwei, eins.
Willst du ein paar Kanneleup?
Frisch geschnitten.
Das klingt wie eine gute Idee.
Also das Ding willst du definitiv nicht ins Gesicht kriegen.
Ich weiß, dass die meisten Menschen stärker sind als eine Melone.
Aber Mann, ich würde nicht davon getroffen werden.
Das ist alles, was ich bis V2 habe.
Ich hoffe, du hast dieses Projekt genossen.
Und vielleicht lernst du etwas.
Ja, auf, wir reden die NASA jetzt.
Ich würde es empfehlen, darauf zu arbeiten.
Es ist eine große Freude.
Was macht denn die NASA gerade?
Über 20 Inch von Regen, die in McEwen geschehen sind.
20 Inch von Regen.
Jetzt fängt es schon an.
Wie wäre es mit gescheiten Einheiten?
Okay, Chat.
Wir raiden die NASA.
Einfach, weil es geht.
Und der Chainlaw sich dann freut.
Und ByteStrike sich dann freut.
Ich habe eigentlich gesagt, ich soll die NASA hosten.
Ich raide jetzt die NASA.
Kona-Zeit.
Das ist eigentlich aus dem Area 51 Naruto Style Run Raid geworden.
Der jetzt hat nicht stattgefunden, oder?
Also Leute, wir sehen uns.
Bis zum nächsten Stream.
Bis dann.
Tschüss.